oh these
testing
all
mic
for
e
so terms let me try that again we'll
open up the public hearing uh for the
Commerce
Committee um you will notice that you
all have we all have these um
microphones in front of us and which
there's a a button to to press it to
speak and evidently only three three
buttons can be on at any moment so so
there will that will somehow cut out um
yesterday I tuned into the Senate uh
Commerce Committee public
hearing and notice that uh the same
mistake was just made the chair didn't
turn on the microphone to start the
hearing uh and second is um that be sure
to turn off your
microphone uh and and I now learned that
I have a mute button let's try the mute
button so my mic still works with the
mute button
I don't I don't I don't know how this
works but just remember after the public
hearing the this mic still might be on
so be conscious of the little side
conversations U you don't want to say
something off mic and then have it show
up
and the rest what it called in-depth
what is that new
s we don't want to be we don't want to
be there again so okay um so I uh this
is my build so I am going to hand the CH
the gavl over to the vice chair you want
me to call the no we don't we don't
care we don't care it's nice that you
have
off
good morning Mr chairman and uh members
of the Commerce Committee I am
representative hunt represent ing ring
and Fitz
William uh today I'm introducing um
House Bill
1039 um House Bill 1039 uh was a uh
resolution of a bill that we passed last
year or the year
before time gets a little fuzzy with Co
um in which it was related to a beverage
manufacturing um having a second
location um it's some of you might
remember we did pass this similar
legislation for wine a couple years
ago and at that time one of the push uh
points was uh did a did someone who is
making wine have
to um manufacture wine in that extra
location which you know in the case if
you were they were to do it in an outlet
type environment it might be kind of
inappropriate for them to be making wine
or beer or something in a in a shopping
mall
um at that time the the the wine people
were given the exemption that that they
could have that second
location uh without having to
manufacture when we pass the legislation
the language that was amended by the
Senate so it's not our fault um we just
left it as it is and nobody pointed out
to us that this could have been a
problem but then uh the department uh
the commission did tried to implement it
and they were unsure about it it was uh
later resolved by the Attorney General's
office so we would just want to clarifi
this amendment was to clarify it once
and for all so we can still discuss
whether we want to still go forward with
just this language or whether we'll hang
our hat on the AG's opinion having said
that uh the department um and because I
this was a even though it doesn't say
Department request it was a sort of a
housekeeping measure to resolve that
issue um we have two other issues that
the department has come up with and they
will introduce to you um I am in support
of both of these issues um I do see them
as
housekeeping um and ensuring that our
laws are are are well addressed U but um
I'll I'll let them introduce those
amendments to you all and with that I
will end my
testimony uh thank you representative on
yes representative Barlett thank you Mr
chair um M I'm just a little bit
confused about what the AG's um
determination was the determination was
that they would not have to manufacture
in that second Outlet thank
you any more
questions U thank you representative
hunt I have one pink card uh from uh Mr
armaganian who supports the bill do you
speak you want to yeah why don't I
because I could introduce maybe the the
the amendment
there
okay um so it is there's two
um uh maybe this is right was it so back
in 2003 and I don't actually remember
this because I was probably around doing
2003 I see here is 2003 that in our
wisdom
multi-year not sure I guess we could we
could this would be a good project for
Kristen to go back and and pull out
exactly what was the reasoning behind
our deciding to have a multi-year
license however um and you'll certainly
hear more about it when we finally do
get to hear the other Bill 1591 but um
the audit uh that that The Liquor
Commission went through pointed out that
since no none of these multi-year
licenses were ever issued why are you
keeping it on your
statute so uh that we can do a little
homework on figuring out why it was
passed in the first place and then
whether they're right that we should
just take and remove it um maybe it's
the Department is supposed to or the
commission is supposed to be promoting
it more that they can you can get your
license for multi-year but I'm pretty
sure most lenses um only like to write a
check they're more willing to write a
check every year rather than one big fat
check every two to three years but so
that's that's what the first section is
and the second section um is uh
addressing um my my favorite law near
and dear to my heart is the direct
shipping
law and um the direct shipping law it
has a statute and related to the
carriers which is going to be UPS and
FedEx and in it um
and I and I have to admit again I don't
remember exactly why we put in this U
90day period it I believe the way my
memory was that if you if you were a bad
boy then you were going to be cut off
for 90 days but we're assuming that
within that 90 days you would have uh
done whatever you needed to do to U
correct the pay your taxes and evidently
we're finding that some don't and so we
we want to make sure that they don't
think that after 90 days they can
suddenly ship again and still not pay
the fine so uh we that that's why they
want to remove that 90day
period thank you represent
representative
Bartlett thank you Mr chair um is it a
little unusual for us to be looking at
an amendment that's been um printed out
by The Liquor Commission and not through
right so this is something yeah in other
words I the subcommittee has to take
this in and
decide whether they want and change the
language exactly this is just a
narrative this is just a narrative to
what what the situation is that they
brought to my attention A and B is that
yes it's up to us so you're just
bringing it up just for the discussion
just bringing it in and so that so that
uh you know they could have waited to
the subcommittee to bring this up but it
was just the fact that we um we now
found that the first issue the main
underlying issue of the bill probably is
not not necessary that I thought maybe
it was a good idea to bring in these
things things at the same time so
everybody has a chance to see them and
hear them and okay so you're considering
I'm sorry can I follow up thank you um
so you're considering um all of what's
in 1039 to be housekeeping is that
correct 1039 was absolutely housekeeping
so there's no big changes as far as how
things operate no and and just
clarification and the same thing with
these two two amendments to me this is
all
housekeeping representative
Terry what I do do I have to hold this
down okay it's on until it's off yeah
it's on uh representative hunt uh with
respect to the indication that language
to be removed is struck through would
you just clarify for me um in section
two within a 90-day period is underlined
but it's not struck through uh uh was
that supposed to be struck through or
are you arguing for retention of that
language I thought you were you were
arguing excuse me are making the case
for eliminating within a 90-day period
but it's only underlying but it's not
struck through okay so if you look to
page it struck
through so so the first page is the
narrative the first page is the
narrative and then the second page is
the actual way the the if we were to
make up an amendment that's what the
needs to look like thank
you representative Weston thanks while
we're talking about striking things true
through uh the first line um on 178
colon 23 you should probably strike
through and multiple Year from the
heading because it'll just be a seasonal
license right just thought I'd bring
that
up well address that in subcommittee
representative
AEL yes thank you um I wonder if we
could get a little more information
about how widespread how common uh
direct shipping direct shippers uh run
into difficulty with the uh not paying
taxes and and or other things uh thank
you uh we do have uh chief of
representative good morning Mr chair and
honorable committee members uh for those
of you that don't know me um my name is
Mark armagan
I'm the chief of enforcement uh and
Licensing for the Liquor Commission uh
some of you might recognize me for my
years prior I was with State Police for
28 years as a bureau Commander over
there um as uh representative hunt has
uh mentioned uh previous to us uh this
is a
housekeeping 100% a housekeeping bill um
that uh we are
supporting um there were items one item
that was brought up in our uh audit that
was to uh uh disallow the multiple year
uh because nobody had asked for it when
it been on the books for a long time um
the 90day I have with me today uh
Lieutenant Matt Culver he's our uh uh
administrative uh commander and and he
uh has been working on this project for
quite a long time with industry uh to
figure it out and uh he can speak to the
numbers that were mentioned just just
prior to us uh coming up
here go thank
you thank you Chief uh chairman and
committee members uh thank you for
allowing me to the opportunity to
address this to answer your question
specifically in 2021 the uh direct
shipping program uh has become immensely
popular um with our out of state uh
permites currently we have about
1363 permites licensed to the state of
New Hampshire who are allowed to Direct
ship from their businesses out of state
directly to Consumers within the state
they do but that by the means of carrier
licenses with the carrier licenses we
have three carriers who deal directly
with the direct shipping program th
those are FedEx FedEx Grant found in
UPS under the carrier license is what
the amendment to the bill is before you
today and that in that law says that um
there's a 90day restriction on
businesses who have not obtained a
direct shipping permit who are shipping
into the state of New
Hampshire when that happens it's
considered an illegal shipment right
they don't have a a uh permit to ship
directly into the state those
occurrences are are happening last year
we um had
154,50 shipments into the state of New
Hampshire 1510 of those were considered
illegal shipments our internal processes
when that
happens when illegal shipment the first
illegal shipment is made into the state
we send that business a letter a letter
in consistent with our education process
in bringing the licenses into compliance
or businesses into compliance we Explain
the law to them we encourage them to get
a direct shipping permit if they ship
again then they're put on this 90-day
list the 90day list is updated every
month at the first of the month and
redistribute it out to all of the
carriers that tells the carriers the
businesses throughout the country that
are pro they're prohibited from
delivering those products to the
residences okay so they they send
products back to the
businesses after those 90 days they come
off of that list so businesses
throughout the country have figured out
that exactly at 90 days they're going to
come off the list and there's no
consequences to them so they will ship
2550 packages every Christmas season
know that they're going to get put on
the 90day list wait the three months and
do it again the next year and that is
circumventing all of the the laws that
we put in place to prohibit this from
happening now The Logical question there
is how much revenue is being lost from
this we simply don't have that answer
because we don't know what was shipped
we only know the carrier reports that we
receive on the packages that are being
delivered not what's in there the 8% fee
that is charged to the direct shippers
is based on how a retail value so how
many bottles are being sold directly to
that
consumer uh I have a question on on the
on the Direct ship is there a you said a
certain percentage of their
uh cases bottles whatever is what 8%
that is the fee yes so we we charge
8% tax or a fee is called in statute um
on the retail value of what they're
shipping
so if they ship a uh bottle for $10 it's
cost them 80 cost them 80 cents okay
that's that that was my question because
I tried to order something uh from a a
place in
Arizona uh and they said they couldn't
ship to New Hampshire so if I know what
this is then I can relay that
information to them so they can exp you
know expand their base into to New
Hampshire and you guys will get some
revenue for it absolutely so thank you
very
much
okay representative representative Terry
uh sir how is it that you ascertain um
what and how
much uh is
um is shipped into the state either
legally or illegally so thank you for
the question do do you get reports from
FedEx and yes so so they they affect and
what kind of therefore what kind of a a
formal relationship do you have with uh
FedEx and and UPS to in effect um report
to you what what they're doing so by law
and thank you for the question by law
they're required both the carriers and
the direct shippers by the 15th of the
month are required to report to us the
carriers report what they've delivered
the direct shippers report what they've
shipped those reports are reconciled so
we can tell off of the direct or the
carrier report what has been delivered
without being shipped that's how we
shipments
repres just a question for the record
would could you state your name in
position again just so I can absolutely
I apologize for that Matthew Culver I'm
the lieutenant for administrative
services within New Hampshire Liquor
Commission division of enforcement and
Licensing thank you anyone else else
couple quick questions so as I
understand it the the shipper UPS is not
held responsible at
all they just have to do the reporting
but they they don't lose the ability to
ship so the UPS FedEx or FedEx ground
are the carriers right and the carriers
if they make a delivery of a package
that is on that list
uh the administrative fine for that is
$100
so that's how they're held accountable
for
that U second question so I get a uh a
shipment of of six bottles of wine from
the Wall Street Wine folks um that comes
under this and the shipper has to notify
that they shipped it to my address
correct okay all right thank you yes on
a monthly basis those reports include
the carrier reports include the
addresses of where they're delivering
this
product so um um at the risk of getting
down too much into the weeds here for
everybody uh you receive or you
you if if if a if your department
determines that a shipment was made
illegally do you on a periodic basis
notify the
shippers who those illegal shipper the
shippers are who are making illegal
shipments then should I stop there am I
correct so far yes so so then if UPS or
FedEx continues to ship and you
ascertain that they shipped even once
they have been notified that the shipper
is shipping illegally then you are able
to hold the shipper liable for that and
to find the shipper that is correct now
so if I might with an
example you you you spoke about
Christmas once a year so you would uh
you they would not know that in advance
because the shipper is not on the list
yet so if if you you determine that a
Christmas shipment was shipped
illegally then you notify FedEx and
UPS and then do they then know that that
uh restriction is in effect for 90 days
only yes the carriers would but I I
think there might be some confusion
still on the process of thank you um and
thank you again for the question uh so
the the carriers when a shipment is made
and delivered by the carrier and in that
shipment the based on the reports are
due to the commission by the 15 15 of
the month so at the 15th of the month is
when we do that reconcile uh reconciling
between the reports and identify what
illegal shipments are made if an illegal
shipment is found in that we send a
letter to the Direct ship the
shipping the business without a permit I
guess is the best way to explain it the
non-licensed permitting business and we
explain to them that they're in
violation of RSA 178 one shipping
without a
license on their first offense so they
they're giving one chance to come back
and get and obtain a a permit with us we
educate them on the law we educate them
on being in violation of the law we
encourage them to get a permit through
the commission if they ship again then
at the beginning of each month we put
them on the 90day list we give that list
to the carriers
the carriers have 15 days to update
their records and then they can no
longer deliver any packages that come
from the non-permitted uh license
non-permitted
business
check gon now thank you gentlemen for uh
answering our questions this morning um
I I see in current statute where you can
find the shipper if they knowingly
ship an illegal shipment is there any
attempt to collect from the the
unlicensed business those consider and
thank you for the question those
considerations have been made our only
alternative for a violation of 1781 is a
class B felony class B felony for outof
State businesses uh I mean provide some
complications you're talking about
extradition back into the state it it is
um not something that has been pursued
time if I can add to that it has been
pursued in the past and uh the cost
Effectiveness has come into play for the
amount of tax that is being um uh
reconciled at that point so we we're
playing against that also uh but that
was through a different
Administration
okay representative
able yes thank you
um to your knowledge
Do Most states have a
similar
process uh those or I should say those
that would allow out of state shipping
uh are you fairly are you following a
process that's pretty pretty common in
the in the United
States thank you for the question and
yes there's many states I don't know how
many offhand uh that do have direct
shipping programs um and these are
consistent with that as far as the 90 uh
day requirement um I could definitely
offand okay thank you very much everyone
um seeing how I have no more pink cards
I have the blue
sheet um Aiden
Moore from the New Hampshire Liquor
Commission supports this Andrew
preventure New Hampshire Brewers
Association supports this Kiren nees
from Tuckerman Brewing Conway supports
this uh Max Abramson uh for himself is
concluded we have 10 minutes before the
next
hearing
easy it's off it's on oh red is
on
e
okay um so normally we would be opening
up the public hearing on uh
1591 uh unfortunately
um the sponsor uh I did talk to him he's
asked that if it would be okay if we
moved it off because uh his co-sponsor
was with someone who uh got co uh the
other co-sponsor uh broke her leg I
guess Margie Marie hurt herself Twisted
her leg or something and uh so um and
let alone Aiden is also in quarantine
too so it better part of valor because I
was still working on the schedule uh
this morning yesterday morning when I
got the notification I was able to
timely uh address this issue so we will
be taking up um House Bill
1591 next Wednesday at
10:15 um and uh hopefully we can uh get
through through that that bill at that
time having said that um um I am as
inviting anybody who uh who is here
today who really would like to test ify
and and can't be here for next week I
can certainly we allow that testimony
otherwise um you know that if you want
to say it in front of the sponsors what
you want to say uh what you know we can
we can certainly wait till next
Wednesday is there any anybody don't oh
we do need a card fill it out afterwards
uh you could fill out and afterwards yes
that's fine here do you need to
introduce the uh bill first excuse me do
you need to introduce the bill first um
like I say that the sponsor is not here
right but
just we're we're at this point we're
just opening the hearing and anybody can
testify and then okay I mean I know that
some people that ceremonies like having
someone in get in and introduce it I
think that's a total waste of time and
and usually the person is introducing
doesn't know anything about the bill
anyway so so why yeah no I I'm for
better for I've never been really to
pushing that that process so uh
introduce yourself please I'm Ian
Freeman uh minister with the sh Free
Church I support the bill um I think
that the Liquor Commission probably just
on its own shouldn't exist but to get
rid of the enforcement Division I
certainly think is a good idea um the
enforcement division basically exists to
generate revenue for uh the state by
going and punishing uh business owners
and other people for violating whatever
the rules are that the division has come
up with adults are certainly able to
handle themselves when it comes to uh
using alcohol some of them aren't uh but
putting those people you know under
criminal charges is not making their
lives any better it doesn't help people
and all it does is it makes the Liquor
Division more of a a presence in
people's lives and it shouldn't be there
at all because prohibition doesn't work
and we learned that 100 years ago uh
that was undone but unfortunately it
just changed forms and now we have
regulation which is just prohibition by
another name uh that's all I have to say
and thanks for listening I support the
bill good uh are you willing to take a
question happy to take any questions
representative bartl has a question
thank you Mr chair so what is your
proposal um uh regarding do you have
another idea of how liquor laws should
be enforced I don't think they should
exist you don't think there should be
any laws at all regarding underage
drinking
um has that ever stopped people from
drinking underage over serving uh again
I think that uh people will make their
own decisions in the marketplace and
they should be free to make those
choices I uh don't want to see people
get hurt but we already know that people
make bad decisions as is and no amount
of laws have stopped that from happening
when it comes to uh when it comes to
alcohol so let's make people make their
choices and suffer whatever their
consequences are if they actually put
other people in danger then there should
be some sort of a prosecution I think
that makes sense uh but otherwise you
know leave them alone isn't that the New
Hampshire way no Live Free or dying you
haven't heard of that okay okay thank
you is anybody else has a question thank
you very
much represent just so I can understand
how this would how this might play out
so if uh if a couple 12 year olds or 11
year olds went into a liquor store and
wanted to buy a bottle of liquor
um and the store owner didn't want to
sell to
them um would would you have it that
that would be the end of it or that the
liquor store owner could sell to the 21
year olds and that would be fine well I
think it would depend on what and and if
I could just finish my question sir and
if if the if the case were to be that
the store owner or the clerk did not
want to sell to the tube 11 year olds or
12 year olds or 10 year
olds um could there do do you see that
charges could be brought against the
owner of the liquor store because he
refused to make a sale that he would
make to that would be made to anybody
else I if you could just speak to those
I'd be interested to see what your
thoughts are because I understand I
understand where you're coming from yeah
I support a free market and that also
includes people's ability to boycott uh
so if that store owner sold to those two
that you're talking about that might
upset people in the community and they
may not want to patronize that person's
store so there can be consequences for
actions that don't involve state
criminal charges on the other hand if
you chose not to sell to those uh to
those two kids there shouldn't of course
there should not be any sort of criminal
charges for that I think A store owner
should be free to discriminate on the
basis of whatever me U you know whether
it's age or whatever they feel like like
you shouldn't even be able to come in my
store if you're you know 12 years old or
whatever people should be able able to
make those choices and let's let the
market
decide thank you okay oh we have more
questions more than I
expected uh just a clarification um are
you representing yourself or the church
um both and what was the name of the
church chree church charer Free Church
thank
you uh yes I have a a hypothetical
question so um there's an adult
bartender and an adult customer in a bar
and the adult customer is is Vis visibly
drunk um two choices the bartender can
serve him again or the individual who's
drunk can make that adult decision of
not to buy a another drink but let's
suppose he does and goes out and
immediately causes an accident whose
fault is that is that the bartender's
fault or is that the adult who is
visibly drunk's fault it's the person
who got behind the wheels fault
every time so the bartender could
legally just keep serving this guy all
day long even though he's visibly drunk
I don't think that they should but I
also don't think that they should be put
in a prison cell for
that how about a how about a civil
liability further question no thank
you okay thank you very much for your
testimony uh is there anyone else who
would like to speak uh okay so I will uh
recess this public hearing till
19th all right we are now in recess
until 1
1:15 where we get to do something even
more
exciting
cryptocurrency
yeah is it
it what it does is make me I can speak
over
everybody
e
we'll open up the public hearing on
House Bill 1502 and here from the prime
sponsor representative Ammon good
Ammon thank you Mr chair good afternoon
committee
members so the next three bills that
we're going to hear are kind of similar
and related so I think I'll put an
introduction in in this testimony and
kind of cover three birds with one stone
if that's okay that's fine that's great
so I have a little personal story I went
to a friend's house uh recently uh for a
housewarming party and he he printed
something out and he gave it to me
laminated as like a momento I think he
was kind of teasing me a little bit so
on on this I don't know if you can see
it I can pass it around uh is a QR code
to purchase honey a jar of
honey and this took place back in 2012
in July so about 10 years ago
almost and he has a picture of me buying
the honey from him it was the first jar
of honey that he sold bees were raised
on his own farm and there's me with apps
that we downloaded from the App Store
purchasing that jar of honey for one
Bitcoin and on the back he has the
transaction information so there that
you can look this up on the blockchain
this this particular transaction at the
time that jar of honey was
$945 and one Bitcoin now is worth about
$44,000 so that's the most expensive jar
of honey that I ever bought in my
life but it was it was a very uh mundane
transaction
and I'll give you a little history in in
New Hampshire we were one of the first
states to pass legislation in
2017 and it came through this committee
uh there was a study commission created
uh and there was a representative from
blockchain industry were appointed uh
Jeremy Kaufman who owns company called
Library out of Manchester was the
governor hasson's appoint
appointee uh and out of that commission
came a bill uh in 2017 that was signed
into law barbaraa biggie was the vice
chair of this committee she was the
Prime sponsor of that
bill and uh that's my recollection I was
a co-sponsor I thought was Laura Jones
she she had sponsored an earlier bill
that kind of went sideways right right
okay um but here's a picture of a
signing ceremony with the governor it
was kind of fun and uh Barbara biggie
wasn't able to attend this she had
another issue but there's uh Bart fouth
who was also on this committee uh he was
one of the co-sponsors and we signed uh
we we held up a banner with the governor
it said build your blockchain powered
economy here in New Hampshire and the
idea was to attract businesses in this
new form of
technology so that's a little background
on on uh New Hampshire's history we were
one of the first bills uh bills to pass
in the
country um and since then other states
have passed
legislation the National
Council on state
legislators State legislatures they keep
track of cryptocurrency legislation
going back to 2017 and our bill is one
of the first in their list as of last
year 2021 they tracked 33 States and
Puerto Rico had pending legislation in
their legislative session and 17 States
enacted legislation or
adopted resolutions um and most of it is
in favor of supporting this
industry I know it's a difficult topic
to understand I'm going to try to make
it as simple as possible
um the technology that was invented that
supports
Bitcoin it's a it was a uh a novel
Innovation um and it's the idea
around representing property rights in
the digital space that's really if you
could fun if you could boil it down to
its fundamental core it's the idea that
a digital token that you can prove that
you own that token uh and that token
gets recorded in a big Ledger that
everyone has access to and you can Pro
you can mathematically prove that you
own that whatever that token
represents and the token can represent
different things it can represent a
number let's say a unit of a virtual
currency it could just a simple number
that you have 10 of something or nine of
something but it can also
represent uh additional types of
information it can represent artwork it
can represent physical real estate it
can represent almost anything that you
can apply property rights to can be app
this technology can apply to that and my
supposition is that most property rights
in the future are going to be proven
with techn techology similar to this
whatever that property is whether it's
virtual whether it's in the metaverse
that we hear a lot about or whether it's
in the real world um so this it's it's
not uh some might characterize Bitcoin
as Beanie Baby fad um it it could be
looked at that but it's a much much
bigger it's on the scale of an
innovation uh similar to the internet
how the internet has changed our lives
this technology is being built out about
much of the Innovation happening on the
Internet is happening in this space um
so that's a little background on that um
so what's happened is different states
have taken a position to try to attract
not only the innovators but also the
capital that that can be represented by
this to their
jurisdiction uh even cities have gotten
into the mix the the city of Miami um
the mayor of the city of Miami is
actively trying to promote innovators in
the space to come to Miami and put their
headquarters there the the newly the
newly sworn in mayor of New York City
Eric Adams who's happens to be a
Democrat he says that he wants to
attract Bitcoin and blockchain
Technology to New York City and there's
quotes in uh CNBC
magazine uh that he says that schools
should add cryptocurrency and blockchain
technology to their curriculum he says
it's it's the new way of paying for
goods and services throughout the entire
globe and that schools much must teach
the technology behind it so this is not
a partisan issue this is you know people
that are Forward Thinking are interested
in the space uh the country recently of
El Salvador has added Bitcoin to its
legal tender laws which is kind of
interesting and they're currently mining
it with energy that they harvest from a
from a volcano so they're using
geothermal energy from a volcano to m
Bitcoin for and they're using that for
their uh their state
treasury so similar laws will pass
around the country Texas uh Nebraska but
particularly Wyoming is way far ahead of
us on uh
attracting this these types of uh this
type of Industry to their state so this
next bill has to do with the banking
industry so we're so I'll introduce 1502
I should have done that at the beginning
House Bill 502 specifically deals with
the banking
industry and in in in summary what it
does is it gives the banking industry um
rules around how to custody digital
assets so that's that's really the the
gist of it
so um we understand like if you if you
look at PayPal they've adopted
cryptocurrency if you look at other uh
you know Financial Services they're
incorporating this into their their
platform you know this type of
technology and this bill here would
would provide guidance through our state
Securities laws to the banking industry
that if they
custody digital assets that they have to
follow certain rules to
protect uh to protect consumers and uh
to make sure that you know someone isn't
defrauded of their valuable property
that happens to be
digital um it provides some definitions
uh around digital assets digital
Securities um it talks about something
called a multi- signature agreement
which is I won't get into what that is
but it's basically if you think of a
nuclear launch you need two keys to
launch the nuclear uh missile that's
what a multi- signature Arrangement
would be so you would have one key and
you'd give another key but together
you'd have to jointly uh unlock
something to make move
it so some of the opposition I think
we'll hear around this bill is that
crypto is volatile and that's true it is
volatile
um the total market cap of all
doll and that doesn't include things
like non-fungible tokens which you've
probably heard a lot about
recently um the Bitcoin itself is about
$800 billion market
cap when we first introduced legislation
around this topic years ago in this
legislature it was it was uh seen as
something so new it was hard to for
people to get their heads around but you
fast forward to today and you turn on
CNBC or Fox Business or whatever
Financial Network you watch and you'll
see the price of Bitcoin quoted along
with all the stock indexes uh as a
matter of fact um Matt Damon has started
doing commercials around one of the
companies um and you know you can't get
away from it it's becoming a much bigger
uh industry and it has as I mentioned in
the beginning it has the potential to
affect anything that requires proof of
property rights whether that's digital
or physical so that's a big umbrella of
potentiality
um I think that's about it for now I
probably have a few more points as we
introduce the the further bills but this
154 they both deal with similar issues
around the rules of coding a digital
asset so if if you hand someone let's
say it's a Mona Lisa a very expensive
piece of art and you you don't want to
keep it in your home you want to give it
to someone to safeguard for you it would
be the rules around how to safeguard
that that that expensive piece of
property that's what this bill deals
with and it applies specifically to the
banking
industry and one final word um I'm open
to amending this improving it and making
it useful for our banking industry so
that we can attract uh you know there's
a saying Capital goes where it's welcome
and this Capital can go anywhere in the
world any nook and cranny of the world
uh regardless of national boundaries
even
so if we make New Hampshire a place that
is welcoming to this Capital but not
only the capital The Innovation the
people that are thinking of new
innovative ways to build products and
services around this we we have a an
opportunity a brief opportunity to make
New Hampshire one of the places that
people uh might want to come to um so
questions questions yes repr me uh yes
uh who who wrote these bills did you
write these yourself or these sort of
cookie cutters that have been presented
at yeah so I I make a $100 a year I
don't have a staff and I'm not an expert
in in this so I I I borrowed these from
Wyoming with the blessing of the Prime
sponsor that sponsored these in Wyoming
okay and his name is Tyler lindome he's
a State Rep a former State Rep in
Wyoming he's now currently Lumis out of
Wyoming
in and Senator Lumis is a big uh crypto
advocate in the US Senate she's part of
I her along with um the senator from uh
Kristen Cinema the two of them are uh
big proponents of this industry in DC
but the prime sponsor was Tyler lindol
and they had a big team in Wyoming
working around this and uh it was
that representative able
yes uh thank you representative amen and
uh thank you for uh your Clarity in uh
in what you just said um my question
is uh there actually could be so many
but uh what is this what is the status
currently of digital Assets in New
Hampshire AB you know absent this law
and how would that how would that change
if this law were enacted that we passed
Fair hands off uh only uh consumer
protection
applied um so this would
ground you know in the last four years
I've seen our lazy Fair attitude has
caused companies in the space who are
used to dealing with regulations they
they didn't know how to they don't know
how to handle our state because other
states have regulations on the books and
because our Market is sort of small um
you know that we're kind of an
afterthought so this would
give some regulatory Clarity around
financial services companies um I'll
mention this because it's public record
uh you know New Hampshire we have really
solid trust laws we kind of like the
Forerunner of really tight trust laws
there's a company called blockfi you've
probably heard of coinbase right
coinbase is uh they they went public
they had their IPO last
year uh on the US Stock
Market um and they're I think a 62
billion doll market cap is I
think they're based in California if I
believe there's other companies in the
space there's one called block
and blockfi has different uh uh crypto
offerings uh you can get a credit card
if you go out to dinner you can earn
crypto as like a cash back reward for
your purchase so
blockfi in new earlier 2021 they filed
with our banking department for a Trust
Company in New Hampshire but they they
pulled it I believe it was in September
so they they came in they were going to
use our trust laws and then they they
went out I don't know the reason for
that it was it's that's all confidential
I don't think I'll ever know but there's
an example of a pretty big company in
that in that space that was tipping
their toe in the water for New Hampshire
and somehow got scared off so if we
could fix that problem with legislation
Juris I could I could Ramble On stop me
if I'm talking too much um in talking to
Tyler uh their banking department they
helped push these bills through and and
many more their banking department is he
says they're flush with cash because
they have annual filings every year from
lots of these companies that are
registering and they're actually Wyoming
is is actually become second to the
state of Delaware for Corporate filing
income and a lot of it has to do with
so represent M leader again uh yes
representative Aman I I may have a
follow-up question but my understanding
that Bitcoin is not considered a
security what we consider a stock or a
bond but I'm I'm looking at
uh um 21-
29 and let me read it to you digital
Securities are in tangental personal
property and should be considered
Securities but then it goes on to say is
defined in RSA 382 etc etc but it is not
a security per se that would be subject
to any rules by the security Security
and Exchange Commission is that
correct yeah so this because there's so
many layers to this technology space
okay so uh Bitcoin is considered a
digital digital property right and bit
bitcoin's kind of like a you could say a
dumb Network it all all it's a big Excel
spreadsheet of who owns what that's
basically what Bitcoin is but there
layers on top of it something called
smart contracts so ethereum is a smart
contract platform and you can create all
kinds of digital tokens that are it
there's something called the Howie test
where they there's a a question going
back I forget was the 1940s or something
um I forget the exact date but there's a
test to decide whether something is a
security or not and you can create on a
smart contract platform you can create
something that looks more like a
security so well so as as a followup um
for example Fidelity has a digital
currency ETF that would be considered a
security would that be correct the ETF
is registered with the SEC okay all
right thank
you so um this one is the UCC
one um and historically I've been
around long enough to every once in a
while the UCC comes down and uh that
comes uh I think it's in Chicago where
they they make these UC and the purpose
of the UCC was to be uniform across the
country and but so if this is going to
be our own uccc form then it's not
necessarily comes from them first words
sort of this is the cart before the
horse because usually we wait until they
have come out with their uccc which I
think they're working on number 12 I
don't know what happened to 10 11 in
between but so number 12 was supposed to
be this wouldn't we be better for us to
wait until they actually come out with
their UCC rather than having to pass
something and then have to repeal it and
replace it with the new UCC
language um I mean there's
philosophical things around relying on
some third party to write our state laws
right so we we wouldn't want to seed our
sovereignty there's a reason why we have
Securities laws in in state statutes and
it's the purview of the legislature to
modify it the downside of waiting is
that it once it's uniform or what once
the federal government comes out with um
it's not federal government I know it's
not either or right and it was designed
so that that laws wouldn't be federal
laws
that each state would take these model
UCC statutes and put them in their own
statute so they would be consistent
across the board so people know what the
law is because it's consistent from
state to state without Federal you know
implications it was done on a state
level at the state level understood um I
guess that it's do we want to have first
move or advantage or not I think that's
the question and also the more states
that adopt legislation like this would
inform that process right they they they
would most likely try to uh you know if
multiple States
had uh digital asset uh changes to their
uccc code that they would incorporate
those in um but it's that first mover
Advantage you know there's a few years
here where uh we could we could uh move
forward and once we attract those
businesses that Capital those ideas you
know those innovators it gives us
uh benefits going forward okay so so
Wyoming had they did change their UCC
statute yes they did along with a few
other states but uh Texas I think is one
and uh so my last question is is you
made the comparison if we had a very
valuable painting and we wanted to have
somebody else hold the valuable
painting we have no state laws
regulating
that so that you're asking us to say to
treat this as a I think the a member of
the banking Department used to call uh
Beanie beanie babies is her comparison
so if we're treating these as special
assets why why should we change from
what our current attitude which is it's
up to those two parties involved to uh
figure out what makes it secure what
makes it safe rather than us getting
involved in that transaction yeah you
know some of my friends are going to get
mad at me for saying this but it's that
the regulatory uncertainty aspect i'
we've seen that with what we did earlier
on that a company that let's say like
blockfi he wants to move from New Jersey
to New Hampshire and they don't have
rules around it uh you know they they
might not know how to how to you know
way okay uh representative Herbert's
next
right
um yesterday I was watching the uh
Senate Banking Committee uh interview
with uh the Federal Reserve chairman
Lewis
Powell and uh Senator
Cheryl
Lumis who was uh in her first term I
think she just was elected to the United
States
Senate uh made reference to uh special
purpose dep atory institutions that
Wyoming already has uh
promulgated but she said she was
severely disappointed in that her
request of chairman Powell to present to
her in the committee a regulatory
structure uh legitimizing uh
cryptocurreny crypto as a
currency so um I could tell from the
action of the chair that he was U not
ready
to talk about it
um I have a uh I think I have a pretty
good understanding of what a currency
is so I
uh my question to you is is the the
ultimate aim of this legislation and I'm
sure there will be further legislation
if this
passes uh is the ultimate aim of the
crypto currency which is which everybody
talks about it as a currency uh will
become uh a legitimate uh uh currency
like the dollar uh in the United
States yeah that that's a really big
question to uh maybe afterwards we can
discuss that a little further my short
answer would be the word cryptocurrency
is kind of a misnomer it's not it's not
a a fiat currency a fiat currency would
be the dollar or the Yen or the Euro
that's issued by a government you know
that this currency is based on
mathematics currency in the in the the
way that you can let's say you had
marbles that people thought were
valuable and you could trade those
marbles right you know or or cigarettes
in prison might be considered a currency
right but it's not a government backed
or issued currency it's um it's it's
it's interesting the the whole process
around Bitcoin was modeled after gold
mining so gold is something you dig out
of the ground takes energy to get out of
the ground and it's you know universally
valued and it's divisible and it doesn't
corrode it has all the characteristics
of a currency um but it would be more
like gold you know it be more like
something that people around the world
have agreed is valuable and the reason
that they agree it's valuable is because
the technology behind it doesn't allow
for um uh counterfeiting
it so like I said I could talk for hours
on this um but so it's it's not there's
actually Arguments for Bitcoin um
enhancing the US Dollar's Reserve
currency status if it's adopted so
there's actually longer arguments
about uh you know if if the US shuns
Bitcoin it could challenge the dollars
US Reserve res ve status or the global
Reserve status but if we embrace it it
actually enhances the dollar as staying
and competing against all the other
currencies
so further question you
may
um I think that you know I think the the
benefits would go to crypto more than
um crypto currency
has has had one very important uh
Financial role to play in the united in
the world as a matter of fact okay over
the past decade or more I'm not sure
exactly when cryptos
became so January 3rd 2009 is the is
when uh since 2009 okay um it's common
knowledge that
uh uh a lot of the
uh illegal activity is uses the crypto
system in order to operate and and I'm
talking and it's in as you said the
trillions people don't understand
exactly how much criminal money there is
in the globe but it's astonishing anyway
the um so it uh crypto
has um been able to uh financially uh
help uh criminal activities everything
from weapon sales to
um uh tax cheating
to uh your question is yeah well it it
has been a primary tool of uh Global
criminal
Capital that disturbs me a little bit
that's your question my question is um
if you associate as you want to do cryp
to activities with the American
dollar uh I have I have some serious
concerns about that Association okay and
do I agree what I believe I believe that
um
so again there's a longer answer to that
um in the beginning governments didn't
know how to deal with cryptocurrency but
they're getting smarter AR around
tracking the transactions on the
blockchain I I showed you this earlier I
know you can't probably see it from your
seat But it includes everything about
how to find that transaction on the
blockchain and if if you know who owns
the key uh going in and you know who's
the who owns the key going out then
you're able to tie those two things
together um I probably have I don't know
five apps on my phone that I can like
this second I could move Bitcoin to
dollars or dollars of Bitcoin uh back
and forth and I can send you dollars I
can send you Bitcoin or any other
currency it's it's already pervasive um
everywhere the fact that like coinbase
or some one of these exchanges you have
to tell them who you are you have to
give them a lot of times your ID and you
know they have a process to verify your
identity and then once they know your
identity and you buy Bitcoin now they
can t they can track those Bitcoin were
were purchased by you at a certain date
and time and so and so the there's it's
it's actually a very transparent system
and as governments around the world are
getting more sophisticated with how to
track the transactions you can actually
track down some of these criminals and
it's getting it's getting easier over
time so um having a legitimate company
to sell you Bitcoin or to convert your
Bitcoin creates a a way to see who's
doing those transactions so that they
can't evade uh law enforcement or this
is remember the dollar bill they wanted
to solve the problem of criminals using
the money the American cash by getting
rid of the $100 bill and even the $20
bill okay so I don't think it's I mean I
understand you're asking the question
and he gave a a decent answer to it so
let's let's move on representative
bar thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Amon you're um being very
patient with us um oh was
s um because you're you're trying trying
to explain a
difficult concept to a bunch of people
that are Bas basically volunteers we
aren't we aren't banking or crypto
experts at all um so I guess that's one
of my concerns is that though we may be
holding the the cards as far as whether
we approve this bill or not how do we
get how do we get more comfortable do
you think maybe there'll be others
that'll speak to us that'll continue to
repeat because repetition is a good
teacher oh okay I think there's some
pros and cons coming behind me and that
I we learn a lot in that debate right so
I think there'll be some of that I mean
this is already law in in at least two
states um Sim law or something similar
so it's it's not I I wish it was the
first and the brand you know the
shiniest newest thing but we kind of
playing a little bit catchup with
legislation similar to this if you know
it's it's kind of been tested already in
in the you know in the real world so
thank you I I'll keep listening okay
thank you representative
Terry uh in thank you in addition to uh
what you've already shared with us um do
do you for can you see any any um any
risks with us
being uh what I'll say uh either late or
last to the game for example waiting for
uh something to come from UCC rather
than following the lead of states such
as Wyoming and did you say Texas Texas
and there's a few others so so so you
see any risks with us not doing anything
and just sitting and waiting that's part
one of my question and part two is given
the fact that there are now laws on the
books and experiences in Wyoming and
Texas have there been any
uh uh reviews yet as to how the laws are
working and uh have there been any
specific problems that need to be
addressed as these two states have led
the way that's a good question I think
Texas is has it's been so recent I don't
there's probably not much history on
that Wyoming Wyoming uh I've only heard
good things from the people that uh
sponsored this legislation in Wyoming
there there there may be downsides to it
um um I'm not aware of any at this point
in time and the first part of my
question is do you foresee any risks
thus being uh waiting and being late or
last so in technology and really any
kind of like Communications Network
there's there's something called the
network effect right so
uh if
you like technolog is kind of sticky if
you like Silicon Valley is where all the
uh entrepreneurs go and they go there
because the that area became known for
that uh type of innovation
so if you wait to last they're going to
find a home somewhere else and to get
them to move from Wyoming or somewhere
else and and you know put their
headquarters in New Hampshire it's gon
to we we'll be picking up the scraps at
that point if we're just on a Level
Playing Field that's the way I see I
think there is a disadvantage in
Waiting representative
gon thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative Ammon uh according to uh
House Bill 1502 it says that uh Banks
would be allowed to provide custodial
services for digital asset property
would then these Banks be subject to the
same reporting requirements such as uh
under the Patriot Act if you deposit
$10,000 that gets reported uh the newly
uh imposed uh $600 in annual
transactions via PayPal or um Vin
those get reported to the IRS now uh
will this will the banks be subject to
any kind of reporting such as that if
there's transactions because like you
just said one Bitcoin is over
$40,000 uh which it's gone down about
$9,000 in the last week since I bought
some uh that's my fault I tanked the
market thank you but uh what what uh
would they be subject to those same
reporting requirements uh someone more
expert in uh the regulations around
banking could answer better but I
believe that's a federal requirement and
I don't know how it applies to digital
assets at the federal level to be honest
with you
um yeah the the Bitcoin roller coaster
guy is like a meme on the internet that
uh was created I don't know if you're
familiar with that does anybody does
that ring a bell with anyway but the
fact that it's the market can be a
roller coaster uh there's a cartoon meme
that was created by a guy in New
Hampshire and and now he's selling
non-fungible token of his meme like uh
and he and he's doing it on the Bitcoin
blockchain with something called
counterparty so that's a New Hampshire
me me you say me I thought it was a me
okay yeah uh quick question I'm not sure
if it's appropriate but the amount of
energy that it takes to um you know um
make these transactions um I I'm hearing
it's astronomical I mean it it really is
not too energy
efficient is that that's a question like
could you sort of address the energy
portion of this I that's sort of a
separate discussion but I will address
it um it depends on the consensus
mechanism of that blockchain so
consensus
is here's a real easy example let's say
you have an Excel spreadsheet or a word
doc
and there's changes being made to it but
you want everyone in the world to agree
on those changes that's consensus right
it's it's a an algorithm to allow
everyone to agree on the same version of
something that's changing and there's
something called proof of work algorithm
that was that's called Satoshi consensus
that's the first algorithm and that does
require energy it requires energy
because it requires computation so
computer requires energy it requires
electrons to to compute and so the the
computation is what creates the
consensus so that's where the energy
consumption comes from but there are
other uh blockchains something called
proof of stake which is requires much
less energy there's something called
Avalanche consensus there's other
algorithms being developed to provide
that consensus that don't require energy
um there there are arguments that
Bitcoin is incentivizing green energy uh
believe it or not um I mentioned the the
example in Argent in El Salvador they're
using geothermal from a volcano uh
there's a project in Pennsylvania so you
have a nuclear power plant the power
plant it's not easy to switch it on and
off right um and for renewable energy
you need base load power because the
sun's not always shining and the wind's
not always blowing right so and you
can't really store electricity on a grid
scale so you need base load power and
that can be provided by natural gas or
or uh Nuclear So in Pennsylvania there's
a project they have a nuclear power
plant it's profitable that the energy is
profitable sometimes and it's not
profitable other times to go on the grid
so they're building a Bitcoin mining
facility next to the nuclear power plant
so when the energy is not profitable to
go onto the grid they turn on the Mining
facility and they cre they create
potential economic energy if you think
about it um so that's a that's a big
that's the size of a nuclear power plant
that project so um now there's that's a
whole another long conversation happy to
have um but the there there's arguments
that it's incentivizing green energy or
you know carbon neutral energy it does
all you could use coal any any kind of
energy you could use to to mine for the
proof of work algorithm but so
interesting question okay great thank
you very much thank you all right uh
chair we'll call on Lisa
tap who's representing herself in
bill good afternoon good afternoon thank
you Mr chair Mr Vice chair and members
of the committee I am signing in and
testifying in favor of all three bills
but with the chair's permission I will
speak just once un otherwise sure we
love that I am both an attorney and a
nurse practitioner here in New Hampshire
I will briefly describe what brought
digital currency to my attention and why
I thought it was better to get it more
widespread in society and then I'll
explain about why I think this is a good
time for it to happen here in New
Hampshire so I first um learned about
the background of of digital currencies
via a white paper that was written that
um described a database that was
immutable and allowed for immediate
action and I thought that was terrific
because as a nurse practitioner and an
attorney in both situations I find that
when people can't immediately appreciate
what they're doing in terms of spending
money or any other action that leads us
to problems down the road so I really
liked that immediacy and I like that
it's open um um speaking to
representative Herbert's concerns about
illegal activity I regular attend the
American Bar Association digital
currency conferences and they're lovely
they uh several attorneys in the field
as well as Federal prosecutors from
several branches of government and this
is a concern of mine as was a concern of
theirs and over and over again what I
hear at those seminars is nothing will
ever top the American dollar as as a
valuable resource for terrorism
unfortunately but when people who engage
in terroristic or predatory activities
use an open blockchain it's a real Boon
to the federal government because it's
all trackable so there was a lot of
interest actually and not shutting down
that kind of activity because it makes
investigation so much easier and I share
that concern and several Federal
prosecutors have allayed those concerns
for me at these conferences that I
attend but I want to go to the most
poignant example of why I thought it
would be good to get digital currencies
more active in our system and that's
because as a nurse Pro ition here at the
state prison up the road I started a
clinic for um for halfway house members
who were about to transition back into
the community and they need to establish
their own health
care and when it came to sitting down
and we literally practice conversations
and many of the the men that I worked
with at that time were not good at
describing what they need so we practice
how you're going to sit down and how
you're going to talk to your physician
about what you need what your health
care concerns are it always went back to
money and I didn't understand that and
then I realized that inability to handle
money had gotten a lot of the men I was
working with into the situation they
were with however if you learn to handle
money via digital currencies you learn
that it's immediate you're not dealing
with credit you're not dealing with
speculation you pay what you have and if
you don't have it you simply can't pay
it and you can't get into as much
trouble so that aspect appealed to me
and I wanted to see that become more
widespread in
society so uh I went back to school I I
attended University of New Hampshire law
school originally in the 1990s and I
went back recently and became certified
in digital currencies um and I believe
I've spoken with representative Bartlett
actually at a digital currency seminar a
couple years ago it's been a wonderful
experience here in New Hampshire I think
we're doing it very responsibly and the
reason that I think it's great to tie in
the banking industry now is because I
want to see this more widespread I want
to see the men that come out of the
prison learn how to interact immediately
like this will be the consequence of the
debt that I take on this will be the
consequence of giving up the money for
what I want and when I provide a service
I can be paid immediately I don't need
to wait for it to clear through a bank
however banks have good experience in
helping people manage those things and I
think if we can bring digital currencies
and banking together as has Wyoming and
some other states that representative
Ammon
referenced I think we could really be a
leader than that I think it teaches
transparency honesty um and it's
immediate a third point I'll make is
it's contactless and the reason I bring
that up is because I have family who
live in New York and they're currently
on isolation due to having
covid-19 and they they had a bill coming
du it's a very standard Bill not a big
deal but they typically go to the bank
or transfer some monies online ahead
ofay paying it well the way things fell
one person's paycheck is not coming into
the same place that it used to they so
they didn't have the ability to transfer
within one Bank online they couldn't get
the funds to where it needed to be
before the bill was due so what we did
was I was able to send them digital
currency through coinbase they set their
coinbase up to interact with the bank
that needed to have this bill paid I
sent it to them within two hours they
were able to pay the bill the only other
option I would have had would be to wire
I mean my family's home on quarantine
they can't go to a bank and none of us
had this kind of time and I realized
this contactless currency this offers a
lot more than I realized immediate
contactless currency is something that
we're ready to go forward with in New
Hampshire I'm here to help I know there
are several crypto Geeks like me who are
here to help as well representative
anaman has led the way with with establ
establishing a presence here so I think
this is a great time to move forward
with this I'd like to see this more
widespread I think it's a Back to Basics
although the technology is new the
actual spending patterns are Back to
Basics this is how you spent money in
the early 20th century you bought what
you had in the bank and could afford you
didn't speculate as much you immediately
saw the consequences of work that you
did and obligations that you took on so
so another reason that I think it's a
good time to move forward with this is
coming out of these American Bar
Association I'm sorry Association
seminars that I attend I realize how
overwhelmed the federal government is
right now I work with prosecutors from
several different divisions of
government and everyone's got too much
on their plate but we have it going on
here you to use a colloquial term we can
do it we can go forward and when they're
able to get to this when the other
things have cleared off their plate
we're there to help um I would analogize
this to 1998 I hosted the barn civil uh
bound Civil Right Forum here in Conquer
New Hampshire it was related to laws and
regulations of use of the internet and
we hosted some people who had argued
seminal case in the second circuit in
Philadelphia and in the years to come
after that we were regularly consulted
for Think Tank ideas that came out of
the conference that we held I think if
we do it here and do it well we're there
to help and make it easier for the
federal government later if they wish to
look toward this
issue and that's about the gist of my
comments I'd be happy to take questions
approves thank you m thank you Mr chair
nice to see you again nice to see you
thank you could I back you up just a
little bit Mr um I I just want to go
through the chain of how you did this
yes um you were helping a family member
yes um you needed to be able to get
digital currency so so they could pay a
bills so you you went to your
account and you sent money to their
account is that correct correct now is
there a bank involved in that yes so
when you're using a digital currency
exchange it cashes out into a bank okay
this was more about logistics they had
the funds but they were in a bank not
attached to the bill that they needed to
pay typically a direct deposit check
comes into that bank but my family
member can't work because he has Co so
we needed to get to the funds into that
bank and so he was just able to go right
on coinbase open up an account that
dumped into that um that bank account
and then I just transferred and it was
faster than trying to go to a bank and
and it was possible because you can't go
to a bank when you're quarantining right
okay so the money went right into the
your digital currency went right into
the account that he opened up yes then
he took that money and it went right
into the bank and then by EFT paid the
bill yeah and I was like why did I not
realize how valuable contactless
currency is in our society let's talk
about that more another great reason why
you I muted thank you very much for your
testimony thank
you uh the chair will call on Amilia
galdi who from the banking department
and the banking Department takes no
position on the bill
I guess I'd like to begin and
congratulate you on your new position
thank
you
sorry um good afternoon my name is
Amelia Galder I'm the Deputy
Commissioner for the State of New
Hampshire and I represent the state of
New Hampshire banking Department thank
you for hearing my testimony um with
regard to hb52 the banking Department
doesn't have a position on the
underlying policy of this bill um
however if this is a direction that the
um legislature would like to go um we do
have some concerns about the um this
bill itself and how it would need to be
changed to make it more workable for the
Department um for first it seems to be
contemplated to be under our
jurisdiction in RSA 397 C I think um and
if it is trying to amend the UCC it
probably belongs with the other UC
Provisions I think um and just some
caution about amending the UCC I know
some other folks have talked about it
and I think you're going to hear from
some other folks who are going to talk
more about it um but um I think one of
the goals of the UCC is to facilitate
interstate commerce and that's why you
want to be very careful about amending
it because you want your uccc to match
other states ucc's so that way when
you're exchanging negotiable instruments
between states and you know if one of
the goals of crypto
currency uh culture or transmission or
what Blain Blain blockchain and whatever
uh piece of it you want to be involved
in you most likely want to be able to
get it to another state um so generally
speaking I think that's a reason to be
very cautious about amending the uccc
and I think more people are going to
talk about that probably today um so a
couple of the highlevel issues that
would need to be resolved in this
putting that issue aside um it talks a
lot about Banks um and bank is a very
defined term and our statutes are
defined a bunch of different ways um
there are many different types of banks
there's um state if you talk about State
Banks that includes trust companies
non-depository trust companies uh
traditional Banks um and so forth um and
it's not defined in this bill um so you
would want to be very careful about who
you're talking about I hear a lot of
talk at least in the last testimony
about what we consider at the banking
Department money transmission that falls
under RSA 399 G it's a ly type um where
this says bank I don't think it
contemplates that but interestingly
397 is part it falls within what's
traditionally considered our Consumer
Credit division um jurisdiction which
includes money transmitters um so just
kind of some confusing things that would
need to be worked out before anything
could move forward on this um there's
one other big or maybe two other big
issues that are that I see just looking
at this on a high level not going line
by line is there seems to be a separate
fee contemplated going to the um Bank
banking Department um that the way that
fee is designed it's not consistent with
our current funding model so that would
need to be amended to be consistent um
addition where is that fee oh gosh I
knew you're going to ask me that let's
see here let's see if I can find it I I
saw was uh it's towards the end0 one10
of1 million related to assets held in
custody yes and I apologize I could not
print the version with the line numbers
right um but that is it yep that's a
little different than anything than any
way we're funded at the banking
Department currently um so you might
want to consider making that
consistent um and where this seems to be
having its own chapter and referring to
broadly a bank once you figure out what
you mean by Bank you may want to build
in some sort if we're if we're going to
be you know having jurisdiction over
these type of transactions or you know I
don't I'm not really sure exactly what's
going on here but if if if you want us
to have jurisdiction you probably want
to have a complaint process for consumer
complaints and that doesn't seem to be
developed in here at all um
traditionally when we regulate an entity
type we want you know consumers come to
us all the time and that's an important
part of what the banking department does
so we would want to make sure that any
consumer who came to us would be taken
care of so I think looking just at this
bill I know it's part of the trio of
bills that you're talking about today
but I don't want to confuse things by
going into the 1504 um now but at a high
level that would be the banking
Department's concerns about this
one and I'm happy to take any questions
so when you came up with director and
examiner and this whole fiscal note is
that what Wyoming has that they really
spend all this kind of money yeah so so
that we did sort of one fiscal note for
1502 and 154 yeah the same um so we
actually went to Wyoming and this is the
Baseline of what Wyoming recommended to
us he actually the commissioner of
Wyoming Albert forkner we spoke with him
he actually recommended asking for more
because they're finding they need more
than this than what we put in our fiscal
note because it's really a truly in
terms of 1504 now um it's really truly
its own regime it's its own division at
the Wyoming banking Department it
requires a division director attorneys
who specialize in
cryptocurrency exam they had to develop
a whole examination procedural manual
because we've never examined anything
like that they hired an outside
consultant to develop theirs because
that was really the only way they could
do it in a safe and sound manner and a
responsible regulatory manner um they
said they would lend us their manual
that they developed but we'd have to pay
for it um because they spent a lot of
money on it Li license us for that yeah
they said they would license it to us I
think um but we didn't really go down
that road with them too much um so he
actually recommended asking for more
than what we recommended so or what we
ended up asking for so The $64,000
Question are they bringing in enough
money to pay for their banking
Department I believe so I I would have
to look into that a little bit more I um
things are a little bit busy at the
banking Department right now so I can't
quite bring that piece of it to mind um
but I know they I believe the last time
I spoke with them they have four of
these special depository entities right
I think um that's
14504 is it four still have you spoken
with that's he said that's 1504 the
other Bill oh I think your number's
right yeah yeah I mean at the end of the
day is because the way we our banking
Department we have fees right and we
have fees for when we come to do our
investigation right but at the end of
the day uh if it doesn't meet what the
cost of the department is we have an
assessment system to go back and and
collect some more money so that the
question I guess you know are they are
they breaking even are they you know
they breaking even over there because we
certainly wouldn't want to get into it
and have this huge bill for the state
and not get the revenue yeah I think
that would be a question so jumping to
1504 I wasn't you know um I have a whole
Spiel I can do about that too um but um
there the way Wyoming is funded is very
different than the way we were funded at
the banking Department I believe and I
believe that this what's contemplated in
here is different than our funding model
well they're they're not self-funded
they're probably General General funded
oh gosh I don't want to say because
I the finance part we're going to have
to just it's just different y okay
y representative
Herbert thank
you this question by the
way my question actually uh comes to me
because of the discussion and it's
a it's a very basic question and maybe
there's somebody here that can answer it
for me better than than you can I I
don't I'm not worried about the fees
because Bitcoin is just stick question
Financial money but uh um my question is
when somebody writes a
check uh in
Bitcoin and it goes to a bank and it
goes to a vendor maybe or the recipient
and it gets turned into
Dollars I'm I'm unclear as to exactly
how that's going on I mean right now as
we sit here today it sounds to me as
though it's not an issue in other words
you can you can order something in
Bitcoin and it'll go to wherever your
bank is and the bank will
automatically uh turn it into
dollars and so therefore therefore the
uh the I I if I'm getting it right uh um
it's I find it very upsetting that we're
actually doing this but uh this means
that um there is no issue uh in terms of
doing business whatever your business is
uh and wherever your business is it
could be you know Puerto Rico or uh
China for that matter well you can't do
it out of China because they they put
the kabash on bitcoin they decided they
weren't going to play but then it's all
it's all very uh fluid in and in as
practical matter we are already
using uh Bitcoin as our
currency okay that's your question that
is my question and I'm still not clear
about the mechanics of it but uh you
know I thought it was not
legal and so obviously at some point it
became very legal for you to say here's
my Bitcoin account and you can there's
my dollar account and they can be uh we
will gladly make the
transition uh so if that's the
case have we already adopted a second
currency no and she will answer your
question okay okay so I think the the
easiest way for me to answer your
question is to say that there are
current we currently licensed money
transmitters who um will take this is
very oversimplified I apologize to all
the Bitcoin enthusiasts who I may be
oversimplifying this for um so we
currently license money transmitters who
will take your Bitcoin and give somebody
else money like dollar fiat currency so
there's a third party involved here we
only regul so we only regulate it when
there is a third party for in terms of
money transmitters if you wanted to give
your Bitcoin to um chairman hunt you
could do that with no like I wouldn't
need nobody would know nobody would need
to be involved um it's a completely
separate thing much like if you gave him
cash nobody would need to be involved in
that um so we currently regulate
entities that take Bitcoin give give out
currency PE out currency we do not
regulate companies that take Bitcoin and
only give Bitcoin that was specifically
Exempted in
2017 you may remember um we went how
could I forget yep we went through uh
that and developed a specific exemption
from our money transmitter laws for
folks who do money transmission of like
the third party with just the crypto on
either side okay one more just question
and you're going to be specific now the
the third party uh in the first
transaction is not a
bank it's somebody who has access to
bitcoin and has agreed
to uh send out those dollars it has
access to but that's not a bank if
somebody's got a a business uh correct
all right I'm I'm not sure I I've never
heard of these organizations we did the
money transfer business so everybody
used to think of Western Union yep okay
or coinbase but and coinbase um and
they're they're in the business they're
they're in there they're doing it are
they US based but I I found that the
that the easiest way to transfer money
to somebody is to go down to my local
Walmart and transfer it to the Walmart
that they're near to them but that's
cash only that's not Bitcoin I don't
believe Walmart is doing Bitcoin I think
Walmart would be is licensed by us
though and that's
they again the license is just a
registration and so that if there was a
Consumer complaint we would know who to
follow and we examine them so these
third parties already exist who
regulates them we do yep we regulate
they're not a bank correct we regulate
um Consumer Credit Division Licenses in
addition to banks credit unions trust
companies then in consumer credit
division we regulate money transmitters
small loan lenders Mortgage Bankers and
Brokers uh I'm missing one sorry yes um
but money transmitters would be the type
of entity that you're talking about
M the beginning of your Mike
Mike uh again thank you for being here
in the beginning of your presentation
you mentioned some of the places where
you thought that this uh existing uh law
was not adequate whether you should
change this this this and that do you
have a maybe an outline of an amendment
that would cover your your concerns that
we could take a look at or do you have
in writing that we could look at of what
you just said um I don't have anything
in writing right at the moment I could
develop something it would be pretty
extensive though for the two bills that
1502 and 1504 um I'm sorry oh I'm sorry
can you hear me okay yeah um so I don't
have anything in writing right now um
but I we are we we have done the
analysis and gone essentially line by
line um on 1502 and 1504 to figure out
what would need to change so so we could
get that yeah yeah absolutely yep
representative
able thank you and thank you for for
testifying um under under
uh house bill
f502 um what would be the
uh what would be the RSA or the uh
the division of the banking Department
that would would control regulating this
kind of an
Endeavor sorry go ahead didn't mean to
cut you off um so we currently as
contemplated by the fiscal note we don't
if you're talking about the three bills
kind of working together to create a new
regulatory regime we do not currently
have a division that could absorb this
type of work that's why we put in the
fiscal note that we would basically need
to establish a new division create
create all the training get the exam
program up and running it would be quite
the Endeavor because we don't have a
now okay great thank you very much thank
not okay got one more card left for 1502
Christy Merill and Ryan hail from the
okay good afternoon um chairman hunt and
honorable members of the House Commerce
and consumer affairs committee uh my
name is Christine Merill and I'm
president of the New Hampshire Bankers
Association um and with me today is also
Ryan hail uh VP government relations for
the New Hampshire Bankers um we
represent 38 member banks which employ
nearly 6,000 employees and we are here
today to provide testimony um opposing
House Bill 1502 um we understand what it
is that um the sponsor is trying to do
and we're very appreciative of that um
you know in a world that is becoming
more reliant on digital transactions
this is an area that our members are
very interested in and we think they
would benefit from additional regulation
um our major concerns with the
legislation are really because it amends
The Uniform Commercial Code I know
that's been talked about a little bit um
and specifically article 9 UM outside of
the uniform law
commission um and in doing so we believe
it undermines the uniformity
that is really Central to the UN Uniform
Commercial Code um the uniform law
commission and I apologize if you're
already aw but for those who are not um
they have a long history of working to
ensure commercial transactions are
treated with uniformity among the
various States uh the uniform law
commission has been working over the
past couple years um specifically to
address emerging Technologies um
including how digital assets are treated
to ensure the laws governing these
assets are reliable and pred predictable
across
jurisdictions they have uh a working
group currently with over 20 members
they each represent various states to
create a new article 12 to address this
they um have told us they are expecting
to wrap up their work later this year
and um they've released an initial draft
which is grounded in their expertise in
this complicated and evolving area I've
included along with my testimony a memo
from the ulc that outlines the work
they're doing um and they also very
specifically address the concerns with
house 1502 and I can in no way say
explain it better than they do so I
would encourage you to take a look at
that we also have other information for
you about um the uniform uniform law
commission the UCC has been adopted in
uniformity in nearly every state and
it's incredibly important to the
business of banking by providing Clarity
around the different types of
transactions and services offered by
Banks um and that also includes
commercial lending it defines how
security interests can be granted Ed
perfected and transferred in property
for lenders article 9 identifies and
differentiates types of collateral and
provides a definition for the different
types of assets and making changes um
outside of that well vetted process on
an ad hoc basis will create confusion um
and we're concerned it has the potential
to invite cross jurisdiction litigation
due to the inconsistencies in the
different states so we are of the
opinion um that the changes to the uccc
should not out not should not occur out
established um to us the the ulc is
vitally important by providing clear and
consistent rules and procedures across
the country to ensure uniformity across
all 50 states but at the same time they
look at each State's unique environment
they have Commissioners from every state
that have a voice in the process and
that includes New Hampshire um I think
we've included this for you but over the
years going back to 1909 New Hampshire
has adopted 102 of their uniform acts um
and so we've got that information for
you again we appreciate what it is that
the sponsor is trying to do um but we
would ask that the committee hold off on
passing this bill and wait for the ulc
to complete their work um which is
coming as we've said and uh we would ask
for you all to vote in our own study or
in expedient to legislate and with that
we will attempt to answer any questions
have um I've heard I've heard today uh
some information as to um how the uh uh
Bitcoin goes into dollars and dollars go
back into Bitcoin which I wasn't clear
about I'm just concerned and I'll repeat
this until I get an answer that
satisfies me I I'm concerned about the
uh ability to launder money and um I
heard that there's there's a two
key uh deal with the Bitcoin uh which I
was under A Ware of and I'm not sure
exactly what that means but but the fact
is uh uh I haven't read any huge front
page news events of a money launderers
being arrested and thrown in the
penitentiary so even though it's
apparently very clear that Bitcoin is
more secure it hasn't occurred yet uh in
the system
so what is do you have any concerns
about the ability of Bitcoin to be used
in uh uh laundering money from Bitcoin
into dollars and back again um thank you
for the question representative um just
speaking to I know you made the comment
about nothing sort of Nefarious being
reported um it's my understanding there
was something that was reported um in
the western part of the state I believe
last year but um as it relates to
bitcoin and the security around it I
think with all of the um various virtual
currencies um and it's this is difficult
to talk about because there's three
bills and I know they are kind of
interrelated but um I think the short
answer is yes and um I think some of the
regulatory schemes that are in place
today for banks help provide safeguards
against that and so what you'll hear
from us and the other um on the other
bills as well is that we're advocating
for um similar treatment that Banks
receive in some aspects Banks today are
um subject to the rules of finsen which
they specifically look at anti-money
laundering and and things like that and
so banks have very specific protocols
that they have to follow to um avoid
anti-money laundering and things like
that so um the short answer is yes um we
think that banks have a regulatory
scheme in place to address those
concerns and so that's why we would
Advocate that um in working with virtual
and digital currencies that they also be
subject to some of these uh same
regulatory uh Frameworks so those
protections are added so I hope that
answers I don't if you want to add
anything to that you could clear it a
little bit the the the uh further
question further question yes sir uh um
the banks themselves had some uh
anti-money
laundering uh
techniques uh do they
apply at at this point in time to uh the
cryptocurrency uh use of
cryptocurrencies anywhere in the world
actually um as representative Ammon
alluded to there are a lot of different
types of cryptocurrency and the issue of
um addressing how secure it is or
addressing criminal activity is still
being debated and I think that's what
this is an important conversation to
have um in at the federal level you know
you're seeing debates between um the
cftc and the SEC in terms of what what
is it is it is a security should it be
regulated by the SEC is it something
else should it be regulated by something
else those are some of the questions
that have not yet been answered um that
I that we believe would be helpful so I
think we are looking to the feds um we
think New Hampshire in its own
uniqueness and individuality has the
opportunity to move in the space but as
it relates to this we think it's really
important to answer some of these
questions at a federal
level thank you representative
gson thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for your your answers this has been
quite a uh quite a discussion and we
still have two more bills to go uh you
you briefly
mentioned uh that the that there are
some states that have not yet adopted
the Uniform Commercial Code therefore it
is not uniform uh it's sort of uniform
so which states have not adopted the
Uniform Commercial Code articles and if
we were to wait for the the UCC this
article 12 to be released or whatever
we're going to wait on uh how does New
Hampshire gain any kind of advantage
over any other states or any other
jurisdictions by waiting how do we how
do we bring ourselves to the Forefront
if we
wait I think that's really a um a policy
question that you all need to decide um
in terms of the states that haven't
adopted the UCC I don't know what they
are I would never profess to be an
expert in that um I would have to defer
to the commission and I have to look
that up I don't know if you know that
information no I just know it's nearly
all 50 states that have adopted and um
and I do know yeah go ahead excuse me
from from what we've been told the
states that have adop like Wyoming have
um it's our understanding that they plan
to amend it to um fix the problems that
um amending article 9 and adopt the work
of the ulc so that again from what we've
been told that is the plan
but just to add to that representative
um I want to clarify that um I think
it's you know I I know New Hampshire has
done a really good job of being at the
Forefront of certain things and so we
are not opposed to um to embracing
cryptocurrency technology by any means
um so I think in our view the the it's a
very complicated question but it's just
the UCC is very important to the
business of banking um you know we have
a lot of out ofate banks that are
members that do business business here
in New Hampshire and you think about you
know lending we have a lot of banks
located in New Hampshire that are
lending across state lines and making
sure that the UCC is intact is really
Central to the business that they do um
you know and if New Hampshire decides to
adopt something outside of that I think
there really could be some confusion
between um what is the what is the
standard of the law and how does that
apply and especially if this article 12
gets adopted later on so um so it's
we're not um we understand that there
are that 's an interest in moving in the
space it's already here there's a lot of
activity going on that's already been
talked about um and we're aware of that
but just as it relates to the uccc
concern great thank you very much uh
having no more cards we'll officially
close the public hearing on
uh in terms of the uh blue sheet the um
do we get the I didn't get the do we get
blue sheet over here but in terms of
people signing in uh online there were
e
all right we'll open up the public
hearing on 1503 and hear from the prime
sponsor I'm sure this will be a somewhat
edited uh introduction since we've
already now got our feet wet
on thank you Mr chair I I'll keep my
comments brief uh I do want to say for
the record that I engaged the banking
Association four to or six to eight
weeks ago to ask them for input on these
bills so uh I'm grateful to hear that
they're uh in favor of this segment but
it uh perhaps we could work together uh
to find a workable solution instead of
just killing uh the baby in the in the
crib um so this bill House Bill 1503 uh
specific was that non PC I'm
sorry we used to say that back in the
day throwing the out with the bath water
it's all about the children
okay so this bill deals with something
called a digital
token uh and it there's definitions in
the bill
around uh you know what what that would
be uh but the idea is a digital token
that meets certain properties would be
Exempted from our state Securities legis
uh Securities
laws um and one of those properties
would be that the token is consumptive
so that means you consume it in exchange
for a a
service um there's there's uh an example
there's a local example in Manchester
New Hampshire there's a company uh
called Library I think one of their
representatives uh will speak after me
um where they did just that they created
a token uh that that uh drives their uh
content um system so I'll try to explain
it briefly and this is just one examp
example there are many examples but this
is one local example U headquartered in
Manchester so we are we're all familiar
with YouTube you can go on YouTube and
you can watch videos okay so on either
end of that there's the content creators
they're the people that are making the
content and then there's the content
consumers the people that are consuming
the content what library did their
Innovation was they created a token
where the content consumers can pay the
content
creators uh these tokens to incentivize
their creation uh and then those tokens
are exchangeable on an open market so
that's one example of what a uh a
consumpt a token with a consum
consumptive purpose is uh and then
there's other uh there's other uh uses
for these kinds of tokens uh some of
that some of them are to provide like
liquidity and something called a
decentralized exchange so there's a
there's a project called um it's called
Thor chain is the name of the project
but it's a decentralized Exchange uses a
token to to balance out the liquidity
pool so that people can transfer uh
their content so here's the basic idea
these utility tokens can be used by
innovators to create something new and
to create an incentive system around
some new service on the internet and
what this bill would do would say if you
uh if you make New Hampshire your home
base that we will uh allow you to create
these Tok tokens uh and you'll be
Exempted from the from the Securities
laws uh I believe consumer protection
would still apply but uh that that's the
basic gist of this bill there's there's
more details in it
but you know mainly it's the definitions
questions oh yes represent
West yes thank you representative Aman I
must say of the three bills this is the
one that I had the most trouble
understanding and the section in
particular I hope maybe you can clarify
for me was on the third page uh from
lines 7 to 20 where you're replacing a
part of the RSA with a totally new
section and it had to do a lot with um
uh limited Partnerships in the original
RSA it was that that whole section was
totally taken out I don't know why it
was removed and then this new copy was
added in could you just clarify what's
going on there yeah I have to admit that
this is a product of 's handiwork so
they they did all of the uh
crosschecking with the with the
rsas
um it's it
basically allows uh you know there's a
there's a written agreement required
uh with an investment advisor uh that
describes these activities so it's
uh that doesn't really clear it up so uh
we do have someone from the Department
Securities Department who should be able
to help you out okay thank you thank
you any other
questions all right see none thank you
very
so uh Lisa you're all set right great
thank you uh so we'll call up Kevin oin
and Barry Glenn who are from the Bureau
position
good afternoon Mr chair pardon me uh my
name is Barry Glennon and I'm the
director of the New Hampshire Bureau of
Securities regulation uh with me here
today is Kevin moin who is a senior
staff attorney uh with the bureau who
will uh speak to the bill uh concerning
uh the proposed legislation which
essentially is seeking an exemption
under the Securities act uh for a
developer of an open chain open
blockchain uh token uh that that token
would not be deemed as a security so
understanding that there is a
complicated piece of legislation uh we
will certainly try to answer any
questions that you have uh at the
conclusion of Our Testimony so turn it
moin thank
you uh and thank you Mr chair committee
um and as the chairman pointed out we
neither uh support nor oppose this it's
a a very worthy topic for discussion uh
cryptocurrency is not going away as we
see with Bitcoin as we see with uh ether
and many other types of uh
cryptocurrencies out there um the
sponsor had mentioned that there is a
test that's used in terms of whether
a particular item that's not a
traditional security is still a security
uh the hoe test and it's a pretty clear
test it goes back uh as was mentioned to
the
1940s and uh basically it says that an
investment contract is a security when
there's an investment of money in a
common
Enterprise with an expectation of
profits derived from the efforts of
others
and that that's essentially what we
apply when we're looking at whether
something is a security or not and
whether there's been a transaction on a
security and so I'd like to point out at
this point we have had no
cases uh finding any type of
cryptocurrency or platform or developer
or seller or facilitator in violation of
the Securities act we haven't had a
problem with that uh I know I was on the
uh same uh commission with uh the
chairman uh looking at cryptocurrencies
years ago uh we reported that at the
time and we're we're happy to report
that there still has not been any
problems um as far as uh
cryptocurrencies or platforms we have
not had any apply to register with us we
have not required any to register with
us at this point so I just I just want
to make that clear uh from the
GetGo so basically we just have some
questions that uh the committee may want
to consider as they look at this bill uh
and really it's about balancing consumer
protection
uh and promoting
cryptocurrencies uh Bitcoin I think it's
already been pointed out Bitcoin and
ether uh are among the uh types of
cryptocurrencies that are not considered
secure Securities uh but what is
interesting is they're often purchased
as Investments uh I think we see that
with Bitcoin for instance with the
Magnificent um changes in the value of
Bitcoin up and down uh basically that's
being driven by speculation uh so there
are a lot of people who look at it that
way uh and as an investment it it is
very
speculative um and be partly because of
the regul nature of it um one thing I
want to look or uh point out is that
this issue is being looked at by a lot
of different uh entities
organizations the federal government is
looking at this uh it's been a big topic
for the Securities and Exchange
Commission uh it's been a topic for the
um cftc the
OCC IRS and a whole bunch of alphab bits
of uh of regulators uh so as far as uh
Federal uh law goes any changes that
come about uh will uh raise the issue of
preemption um and this would definitely
be considered I believe um to be
interstate
commerce uh so it could raise questions
at that point is this regulation only
going to apply in inate which uh um you
know it it it would obviously be an
issue for cryptocurrency because we're
not talking about something that stays
within state
lines um it's also been noted that there
have been various approaches by the
various states to cryptocurrency ranging
from Wyoming uh from which uh this uh
bill and the other two bills have been
drawn all the way to New York and New
York actually required Rees uh licensing
of uh companies that deal in
cryptocurrencies as I understand it the
uniform law commission has been
mentioned they actually had put out a uh
model uh rule on this and uh it had some
issues uh they actually told States not
to adopt it because they were looking at
it further so it is being looked at by
the uniform law Commission
so um it's certainly an area that's in
flux and I think um you know the commit
committee probably would want to be
aware that this is an area that's in
flux that it's in there's a lot of
discussions uh about this um and
specifically we have some questions
regarding uh within the statute um the
definitions particularly consumptive
purpose
uh it's not absolutely clear to us what
that means and it it's not defined
within the
statute uh the other thing that we
pointed out and it's in our fiscal note
is that um right now we have no system
to handle electronic notice filings as
proposed in the bill uh and and of
course there would be some cost with
that we don't know what that would be at
this point uh so those are those are
some of the issu isues uh that we've
looked at some of the questions we've
looked at that we uh we hope the
committee will uh take a look at as they
examine uh what would be a fairly
significant change to the uh security
statute and uh with that we'll be
questions I have a question regarding
are you opposed or are you in favor we
are neither opposed nor in favor okay
thank you just just again want to make
the committee aware of some questions on
the
bill so my question is
um is any of this activity that that's
uh contemplated here going on now in New
Hampshire
unregulated uh it very well could be and
again there's been no complaints there's
been no uh requirements that we've had
to you know you need to see us to get
registered uh no investigations of
unregistered activity any any issues we
have looked at with regards to
cryptocurrencies is using them in the
purchase of Securities rather than the
actual Crypt cryptocurrencies themselves
right I guess um you when I first saw
the security the first thing came up to
me was the um issue that we we actually
tax Securities and it's a revenue maker
to the state in New Hampshire and but I
my I guess I want to make sure that this
this is outside of those bundles that
are that are offered to the public right
this is because this contemplates a
onetoone exch uh interaction between two
people and it's not a prospectus that we
are currently
taxing yeah sure go ahead uh that is
correct uh Mr chair to a certain degree
I believe the legislation does require
that the issuer or the developer of the
uh token uh file registration with the
bureau uh however that they would be
exempt under almost all provisions of
the Securities act but for fraud U so
that if there was some fraudulent
activity in the course of uh of the
activity uh the bureau may have
jurisdiction but I think it is important
to uh point out as attorney moin
mentioned that uh a lot of the testimony
today I'm kind of paraphrasing you but
um a lot of the testimony today deals
with you know with the consumptive
purpose and how this would be used for
the purchase and sale of of items uh our
concern certainly with the bureau at the
bureau uh is that if this is being sold
for investment purposes and being
marketed as such as an investment uh you
know under the Howe test as attorney
Moen noted uh we would you know deem you
know that particular transaction to be a
security uh and would want to retain you
know regulatory authority over that
which we would if there's fraudulent
conduct all other matters related
to uh the activity uh as written here or
as as deleted in certain sections of the
ACT uh you know would not would not be
there well and I'm glad you brought that
up because um obviously that is really
the heart of the matter of what this
committee should be concerned about
which is the fraudulent and consumer
protection and we have uh anybody I
might you know that use my favorite
frm and that oh yeah it's we we Reg reg
with Securities because of the
transaction but then what actual
Authority do you have over what was
going on when in terms if there was U
some misleading information occurring
and what is your Authority and where you
know and
whereas my attitude is right now it's
all under the it it cannot regulate you
cannot you know you would not be
protecting them they would be under the
consumer protection act and my fear
anytime when we have this registration
is that that's the you know the
campell's nose Under the Tent of trying
to pretend like oh I'm regulated but I'm
not really regulated so is as you when
you read this language here do you see
that potential exposure that we had
under
FM I I would point out that it's not a
full registration that would occur under
the statute it's it's what's referred to
as a notice filing registration and
essentially what it means is that while
we get get a notification that this
organization is operating or or these
individuals are operating in New
Hampshire it's not the same as
registration where we would require
extra information where there would be a
prospectus that we would go through
thoroughly um so you know there is that
possibility I guess that some people
could look at this as as almost like a a
stamp of approval that a notice filing
has been made um and right now I guess
to some extent uh you know the caveat
empor
applies um so uh at yeah at this point
um if we were to adopt this you know
there would be that notice filing that
we have but it it could be taken by some
people that this gives us some type of
authority that we really don't have uh
the only Authority being to pursue fraud
when we're made aware of it right well
that Bingo that's the question so uh at
this point if the fraud were occur would
then you would be referring them to the
Attorney General's office or would you
actually I mean it's uh again it it I
think about how some Securities when you
when
you you you join the the trust
department they they send you the not
big notices that you keep getting all
the time that that you know that this is
fluctuated it's not secured by the you
know the FDIC that you you could
potentially lose everything all right
that's not going to come with the
consumer is not going to get that in
this statute right because that's only
you know uh that's only when it comes to
a perspectiv so in this case we're just
talking about that
notification and someone could be how do
we make sure that notification occurs
without the consumer being misled to
think that uh there's there's somebody
overlooking the transaction otherwise
notifying them that like we do right now
with the banking Department that has a
big you know message there is that no we
don't we
aren't ensuring anything that goes on
here and if you have a problem call the
A's office right right yeah and and um
you know again what we would do is if we
saw activity that uh somebody brought to
our attention we'd app apply that how we
test to see whether it involved an
investment contract essentially uh
otherwise yeah it probably would be
referred to the Attorney General's
office but yeah I I I think that is an
issue with our uh secur firms they have
disclosures they need to make um and
you're not going to see that necessarily
in these types of transactions and I and
I will point out that that other states
that have looked at this have seen
situations
where it's not necessarily clear what is
a consumer transaction versus an
investment or or it may be sold in such
a way that it becomes an investment so
there there are gray areas um and I
think you know that that's where uh the
the hoe test gives us really a a
very good level of um understanding as
to whether we're dealing with the
security or not and again at this point
we we just haven't seen
that
okay representative gson thank you Mr
chairman thank you gentlemen for
answering our questions in reading the
wording of the definition of a token the
purpose of the token that's described in
in this bill uh it's and this is on the
uh enacting page uh under State of New
Hampshire in the year of Our Lord 2022
go on down to lines 10 through 14 the
purpose of the token is for a
consumptive purpose which shall only be
exchangeable for or provided for the
receipt of goods services or content
including rights of access to Goods
services or content and the developer or
seller of the token did not sell the
token to the initial buyer as a
financial
investment how is this any different
from a gift card and is a gift card an
investment or a security that would be
covered under the Securities Department
um no I it's just that a gift card is
kind of a gift card whereas a uh digital
uh token a cryptocurrency comes in all
kinds of
flavors um so again it and there's
probably a way of getting it that
because again as as been mentioned
cryptocurrencies are here to stay and
Regulators have to deal with that um but
there definitely are gray areas um and I
think you're not likely to see see that
with a gift card
versus
um a digital currency that may have uh
nuances in terms of the contracts that
uh might be incorporated into the uh
digital token uh and there may even be
nuances in the way they're marketed
where you know sometimes uh an
investment or marketing and investment
is in the eye of the
beholder um so uh it it's again I'm
certain that it's not
something uh or that I'm certain that it
is something that can be uh
understood but there are gray areas
you thank you uh I just do have one
other thought Bitcoin has been going up
at an enormous rate you know since it's
in Inception and I'm wondering maybe the
reason there haven't been any complaints
when people invest in Bitcoin is because
there haven't been any losses yet do you
foresee there being more problems once
there losses um well I think I've seen
some laughter over here and I I believe
there's there's been a rough ride more
recently with Bitcoin okay I stand
corrected we haven't gotten any comps
and there there have been periods where
there have been rough rides with okay I
wasn't aware of that thank you no
problem
representative Herbert simple question
in the
futuree I would like to know when
somebody's sorry thanks when somebody is
uh discussing uh giving us information
and advice from here whether or not they
cryptocurrency uh
what I just want to know if they have a
vested interest in the uh in the
product me personally actually I just
thought of it it wasn't anything you
guys said I just yeah and I also do not
own any
cryptocurrency and I do believe the
sponsor did tell us that he
owns Bitcoin I just would like to know
uh I I knew that but uh uh you know if
somebody comes forward and I don't know
them I would just like to know well yeah
yeah that's a very awkward question it's
like asking anybody who cares about
vaccine medication whether you own stock
and fizer you know come on you know we
don't ask each other those kind of
questions pardon me I didn't hear you um
it'd be like when we talk about vaccines
should we ask somebody whether they own
stock in fiser or Manda you know do you
have Pharmaceutical stock if you own
pharmac stock you might have a different
attitude about vaccines that's why you
question that's why I ask thank you
chair thank you Mr chair we're just been
our testimony and
writing appreciate it thank
you
representative
yes I'm a
co-sponsor and I own crypto but not
Bitcoin um chairman hunt and members of
the Commerce and consumer affairs
committee thank you for the opportunity
to testify on HB 1503 uh my name is Lex
Berney I represent Grafton District 9 I
am a co-sponsor on this bill and I have
been a professional software developer
for the past two decades for the past 3
years I've been employed at library Inc
a New Hampshire company based in
Manchester New Hampshire and we are
building a decentralized alternative to
YouTube using blockchain
Technologies uh our platform has 40
million unique users per month viewing a
catalog of 15 million videos uploaded by
1 million creators today library is the
biggest decentralized decentralized
alternative to YouTube the 15 million
videos on our platform are recorded on
the library blockchain this is the core
feature of our blockchain and how our
tokens are consumed creators consume
tokens in order to publish content and
regular users consume tokens by
supporting specific content supported
content Rises higher in search results
we believe our technology fits within
the framework set up by
hp53 unfortunately this bill is not yet
law and even more unfortunate the
federal government does not have a
framework in place to regulate a company
such as ours instead of establishing a
legal framework to let us operate in a
safe and regulated manner the federal
government via the Securities and
Exchange Commission has taken a path to
squash all innovation in this area
Library Inc like many other crypto
companies was sued by the secc um over a
year ago and has already spent over a
million dollars in legal fees money
which would have otherwise been spent
expanding our New Hampshire office and
continuing to build our
platform we intend to continue fighting
and hope to win the SEC lawsuit but
there are many other companies all over
the United States which which which
decided to settle and simply shut down
passing this legislation will not be a
silver bullet but it will by joining
with other states that have passed
similar laws begin to form a consensus
on how this industry can be regulated
and we hope that future blockchain
startups can avoid the uncertainty and
legal cost which we continue to endure
thank you for your consideration of this
very important legislation to provide
much needed Clarity for individuals and
space uh do you have any questions any
questions
uh representative Herbert ask a question
this is a question right
yes um could you tell me what you do
again I didn't quite get it I didn't
understand what you your service is oh
our service so uh are you familiar with
YouTube sure okay so we're we're a
competitor to YouTube That's
decentralized where instead of having to
go to a website to watch the video you
can uh watch the videos using your
computer but connect ing to other people
who are also connected to the same
network but there's no Central Computer
uh where the videos are stored they're
shared on everybody's
computer so you allow me to avoid
YouTube you yeah you could use this as
an alternative it doesn't have
everything that YouTube has but we have
15 million videos so that's quite a
bit good to know
okay representative AEL yes thank you
representative um I have to admit that
I've was I've been somewhat confused by
this bill the Bill's clear but I don't
understand what it's trying to achieve
um and perhaps you can explain let me
let me just tell you what confuses
me uh it appears that New Hampshire does
not uh consider blockchain transactions
as uh or cryptocurrency transactions as
as being uh uh something covered by as a
as a uh security and yet we have a bill
asking asking for an exemption from that
and so I'm not sure what the problem is
since New Hampshire already is not
considering this to be a
security uh unless I misunderstood you
you are correct um the issue is that New
Hampshire doesn't uh doesn't have a
definition and doesn't regulate the
space and the federal government also
doesn't have uh definition
and doesn't regulate the space except
for the Securities and Exchange
Commission has decided that
cryptocurrencies are securities and so
any company that does anything in the
space they consider a security and
they've just started suing every company
that has anything to do with with uh
blockchain so by passing this
legislation like I said in my testimony
this isn't a silver bullet so this won't
solve our problem but it's it starts
down the path of having you know like
wyom in Texas right these states are
passing legislation that um explicitly
allows what we're already doing and
therefore if the federal government
tries to go in we can say well we've
registered with the state we've followed
all the state laws you don't defi you
you haven't you haven't specified how
we're supposed to do it because one of
the problems we have with with a with a
lawsuit is that when we ask us to see
how what can we do to be legitimate what
can we do for you not to continue suing
us and they can't answer that
so part of this would be we you know we
can at least show that there's a state
law and we followed the state law to the
te and therefore you know we're
legitimate so that that's that's the
reason is is is is to regulate it so
that we can say we have followed the law
because right now we can't there's no um
there's no
regulation but in the end of the day if
the SEC has the right to ignore the
state law yes I mean they can but
hopefully if there is a state law then
there's a little bit you know there's
there's a u sort of I I I guess yeah I
can't answer
that it just it helps right if there is
a state law that you are following and
if the federal government I mean there's
there's other laws that states don't
exactly align with the with the federal
laws there's compar to the marijuana law
exactly is that at some point in time
the other shoe could drop and the FEDS
decide to enforce the and ignore the
state laws but at this point so in a
sense by passing this we would be you
know one of the few states that are kind
of setting the policy forward and then
if the federal government if the shoe
were to drop then they may adopt the
existing laws that the states have that
several states have already passed just
to kind of keep things
saying fair
enough no more questions thank you very
much for your testimony thank you sorry
about misplacing your card okay uh just
uh before I close the hearing um on the
uh midnight uh posting of uh uh this
hearing the remote testimony we had two
support and 27
opposed and um here in the committee
room we
had it must be Suzanne Smith
representative Smith who's in opposed to
it uh Sarah Reid is in support Joe
Alexander in support Lisa Tapas in
support uh represent Mark wardens in
support and and represent pres is in
support with that I will close the
public hearing and open the final public
hearing on 1
154 and the sponsor will be even more
brief I will try 6 succinct so this
piece of legislation uh creates a new
type of Charter and it's called a
special purpose depository
institution uh again again it provides
rules and protections on how to handle
custody of a digital asset and there's
an expression uh in cryptocurrency and
it it goes like this not your keys not
your coin that that's a very common
refrain and what it means is if unless
you have the magic number the private
key that represents what you own unless
you have that in your possession you
don't really own it and
um not everybody is capable of
protecting you know of handling the
responsibility of managing their digital
keys so that's where these third parties
would come in they would provide the
custody uh you know they'd have
procedures and practices around securely
custody your digital asset and so the
the uh special purpose depository
institution I think um the the uh the uh
staffer from the banking Department
mentioned that Wyoming has four of these
they're Bas basically a special kind of
bank and they have four of these
chartered in Wyoming uh
currently um one of them is one of the I
think the third largest cryptocurrency
Exchange in the US which is called
Kraken um I believe there're the third
largest uh and binance and coinbase are
two other large ones but um the main
thing about this bill um
and you have to forgive me I don't have
the line memorized but it has to do with
hypothecation so basically a bank is
allowed to take deposits and then lend
out some of those deposits right up to a
certain fraction they can I don't I
don't know exactly what the fraction is
currently it might be 7% or something
close to that so you give me $100 I can
loan out 93 dollars and charge interest
on that um a special purpose depository
Institution would require 100% reserves
so they they're not able to hypothecate
their deposits the way that a normal
Bank does and the reason for that is
because cryptocurrency it's you know
some of it's in in its infancy and there
are fluctuations in the price that it
would be dangerous it could provide
systemic risk to the system if you let
uh you know if you let fractional uh uh
lending happen on those based on those
deposits so that's kind of the key
um idea in this bill the rest of it has
to do with how do you Charter a special
purpose depository institution what are
the you know the Hoops that you have to
go through to Charter it what happens if
you don't uh live up to your obligations
uh what kind of recourse does the
banking Department have to uh you know
uh take control of your institution that
isn't behaving correctly why would an
institution like this be interesting uh
you know why why why would someone want
want to create an institution like this
um that's that's kind of a significant
question um we're
seeing we're seeing companies that have
significant cash
reserves take some of that cash and put
it into
cryptocurrency uh to protect them from
inflation so that's one thing that's
happening um and again it's volatile
over the short time frame but over a
long time frame it's uh you know it it
goes up and down but the long time frame
is uh is more up than down so that's why
they do it there's a company called
micro strategy uh they're a software
company and they've invested hundreds of
millions of dollars they they've taken
their cash reserves put it into Bitcoin
and so that would be a use case for the
special purpose depository institution
where they could custody that
significant amount of uh of assets for a
company like micro strategy um
uh Speedy is is the short way to say the
acronym Speedy um but there there they
perform things like on an off-ramps uh
an asset management support they could
it could be support for again anything
with property rights ownership where
that can be tokenized so it could be
real estate it could be oil field
equipment it could be Transportation
assets anything that's non-fungible that
can be bundled uh and and store you know
the ownership proven by a digital
token can be a digital asset that a
speedy could custody
um again this is a big it's not Beanie
Babies this is like the future of how we
prove ownership to each other uh and
it's going to be done in this this
digital asset space and so this would
create a I think a fourth uh type of
Charter if I'm if I'm not incorrect we
would have a bank credit union and a
trust uh this would be an additional
type of
Charter so with that I'll take any
questions and we do have some questions
representative
Bartlett thank you Mr chair thanks again
representative Emon
um each of these bills relate to each
other yes that's correct y so what
happens if only part of these bills move
forward well we could rectify like let's
say definition that's not included in
one but is in another you know we could
rectify that so I think I believe the
Speedy bills stand alone but I could be
wrong okay it it does relate to there's
similar language in this bill as there
is in
1502 and if you remember the the fiscal
statement for both was the same so that
gives you an indication of that they're
structurally similar but the 152 applies
to the banking industry currently and
this would create sort of a new type of
Bank that wouldn't be FDIC insured
there's a provision in the bill that
requires them to tell the customer that
they're not FDIC insured but they would
you know they would specialize in uh
custody a digital asset all the security
that's involved with that whether it's
online security or you know maybe
there's a fence around the the facility
where they keep it whatever that
whatever best practices there are in
cusing a digital asset these
institutions would be specialists in
that for the question question um
so I guess I'm what I'm I I think what
we're struggling with what we're going
to struggle with um and I'm not on the
subcommittee but the subcommittee is
going to struggle with too is If part of
this moves forward to just say putting a
structure in place but not allow not
pulling the trigger not really allowing
it to happen how does that affect the
industry
um the industry will go somewhere else I
mean that's you know the industry is
going to countries that are uh that are
being open-minded to this type of thing
so we're competing not only with other
countries but with other states um so I
mean time is sort of of the essence this
again Bitcoin was invented 13 years ago
so it's you know and and in uh internet
land that's a very long time ago right
but we're getting to the point where
where everybody's coming to the
conclusion that this is here to stay
it's not going away you know do we want
to be last to get on board because you
know what would be left over for us as a
state you know to again attract Capital
so this is capital is very fluid it can
go anywhere in the world it can go just
like your internet access Can it can go
anywhere in the world um and there's a
lot of big thinkers in this space
there's a lot of like a lot of the tech
Innovation that's happening is happening
all around around the space it's it's if
you talk about like an evolution of
Technology it's such a rapid evolution
in the space and it's all based on you
know the foundational Innovation so do
we want to attract the capital do we
want to attract the intellect you know
do we want our universities to be uh in
an area where this is attracted uh you
know attractive to that kind of talent
so thank you that your
question representative Herbert turn
your mic on
please so these organizations will be
100%
Bitcoin am I right yeah Bitcoin or
whatever digital asset you're talking
about it could be dollars it could be
whatever not dollars uh I believe it
could be gold or silver physical gold or
silver but I don't think that this is
being used that way in you know places
where it's adopted
okay I just mention the way you just
explained it to me that's 100% reserves
on on the Bitcoin not the other
things they would have to keep 100%
reserve on the deposit on the Bitcoin
deposit right digital asset dig generic
term for that yeah so um I'm curious as
to the tax consequences so if if uh
somebody has a an account a Bitcoin
account and then they put some 100 acres
of property into that account and then
they they decide to sell
it normally there would be a a purchase
price and then a tax that would trigger
a taxable event so I'm just
curious how that works under this system
well anytime you sell digital a digital
currency or asset digital asset it Tri
would trigger a capital gains uh tax so
short term or long term depending on how
long you hold it so I I think that would
be the answer that it would trigger no I
don't have I don't have a problem with
the currency pipe I'm talking about the
hard
assets the hard asset
um so that's I think tying the digital
token to a physical asset is that what
you're talking about I think so I think
that's coming it's not quite here yet
but uh in certain industries they're
using it like to track you know Liv
stock for instance um but down the road
you could see that your your house that
you live in you could prove ownership
with that digital token and it's stored
on the blockchain that no one can change
so we're not quite there yet I think is
would be the right answer okay thanks
well I guess the question is he saying
is if the transaction was all
done in
cryptocurrency How can there be a
capital gains if it was never
transferred into dollars
uh I think it's on the honor
System go everywhere right right but
again this is about this is about
custody the digital asset this is what
this institution would do that they
would they would securely they would be
like the Brinks Vault for a digital
asset well but if we're going to compare
it to a stock that you're holding the
stock is going to pay a
dividend that can happen in crypto too
and so when that dividends getting paid
it's got to be recorded and if it's paid
in crypto then you're going to have to
translate it for dollars for tax
purposes it's on the honor System
currently but there I mentioned
different consensus mechanisms earlier
proof of stake you get rewarded uh for
for taking some crypto and kind of
encumbering it for a period of time and
then you'll get rewards sort of like a
dividend so that that's happening
already right so but I think where his
question is coming from is his concern
is that it it create even though you're
talking about an honor honor System that
that I think that was uh a lot of people
who believe the reason this technology
exists the reason it's occurring is that
people want to avoid taxation that they
wanted to be out of dollars they of they
wanted to be in this other world that
that the government couldn't get its
paws on and tax it you could do that if
you wanted to but anytime there's an
on-ramp or an offramp to a fiat currency
that's where the government can control
who who's doing what and that's that
seems to be you know the that's the main
uh right but you could be sitting there
for years doing that and then when it
comes finally time to the offramp and
decide to turn it into to greenbacks and
and how the hell are we going to trace
all the transac and how to figure out
well it's like cash right like what the
capital gains really
was uh a good question I don't have the
answer to that but you know I could mow
your lawn you could pay me in Bitcoin I
could mow 100 Lawns and get paid in
Bitcoin and then I could go find a
farmer to sell me a cow for Bitcoin
right that that would never touch cash
exactly it's possible but it's not
practical
right okay representative M well just a
quick comment on the material that I've
read is that actually capital gains
would be uh easy to to trace back with
uh with the blockchain so whatever but
my question to you Mr amens is this
speedy this could be a totally separate
uh company that came into uh New
Hampshire or the Bank of New Hampshire
could create a a new division which
would be a speedy is that correct yeah
that's my understanding that you could
have a a a corporation could own another
Corporation and that that child
Corporation could be a speedy Bank
second question um is there such thing
as a Bitcoin backed credit
card there are products in the
marketplace that you can send your
Bitcoin to an address they'll send you a
Visa card in the mail and then you can
use that Visa card to pay for your your
groceries it would seem to me if that if
I went over seas with a Bitcoin uh
credit card that I wouldn't have any of
the transaction costs of having to
convert my currency that that is a big
uh there's a longer conversation around
that but that is the the you know it's
to replace sort of Western Union where
they charge you an exorbitant fee you
can do it for fractions of a penny as a
matter of fact I mentioned El Salvador
earlier that they've added Bitcoin to
their uh their uh you know their legal
tender laws they have there's Al
salvadorians earning a living in in the
United States and they're sending their
relatives their earnings in Bitcoin back
in El Salvador and then their relatives
are able to go to the coffee shop and
buy things or the you know the market so
that is that uh is eliminating a a
middleman like Western Union from
charging exorbitant fees that's one use
case for it
yeah right but Rick Steve told me last
night that it's always best to get your
money exchange at the ATM you get the
best exchange
rate representative
gson thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative Ammon uh how does a one
of the these new special purpose
depository institutions make a profit if
they have to have 100%
reserves where's it what's in it for
them they would charge a fee uh you know
they would they they would charge their
customers probably an annual fee or
whatever fee structure they came up with
and in exchange for you being able to
sleep soundly at night knowing that your
gazillion Bitcoin or whatever it is is
safely stored right but you have you
have it based on the deposit
If I deposit 100 million Bitcoin or
whatever well there's a there's an
agency fee is that what you're referring
to there's an agency fee based on the
deposit oh I must have over which would
be different yeah okay I I might have
over overlooked that but are there
transaction fees applied as well if I
want to do this uh transfer from A to B
whatever this onr onramp off-ramp is
there is there coming and going fees as
well because no bank is going to not
make money coming and going that would
be up to the terms of
yeah that would be up to the terms of
service whatever is competitive in the
marketplace right
yeah great thank you thank you oh well
yes
represent uh I want to commend you on
your um presentation you did a great job
thank you kind of explaining you know um
the U Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies but
my question to you is as a Republican
representative um this is an expansion
of government and there is a impact
could you maybe address how you feel
about that it's very interesting yeah
I'm
conflicted yeah but so we we did that La
Fair law in
2017 and we had trouble getting
companies to pay attention to New
Hampshire because they didn't know how
to interface with the state every other
state had some kind of regulatory regime
so that's really what changed my mind
about this particular industry is that
you know and we're not a big state so
you know we're not Texas we're not
California um that uncertainty scares
away the the uh entrepreneurs in the
space are deathly afraid of getting in
trouble with the regulation because of
some of the reputation around this stuff
right so uh I think having some clarity
in our regulations and making it
inviting uh would attract you know that
industry to our it's it's an industry
that's going to be here from now on
right and be able to attract it early to
our state would be a benefit for
everybody I think so that that's how I
justify my my lack of principle that you
pointed
out thank you believe you me I asked him
that
right okay thank you very much than you
oh I'm sorry represent gon has another
question just a very quick would you
believe would you believe New Hampshire
is larger in population than the state
of Wyoming so Wyoming can do it we can
too we can too that's a good point but
they do have a different banking
structure right why not so there there
is an interesting twist that uh New
Hampshire we are assessment system so
our banks pay for the Department same
with insurance but Vermont for instance
is not in Vermont everything is General
funds so all right uh milia
gard and Nancy
dagel
Renault what do we think about creating
division
and we won't accuse you of build of
Empire Building here on this
you H good afternoon uh again my name is
Amelia Galder and I'm the Deputy
Commissioner for the New Hampshire
banking Department with me is Nancy deel
renad she is the director of trust
supervision at the banking Department
thank you for taking our testimony today
um so I did distribute a handout I hope
I had enough copies for everyone if
anyone needs more I can can certainly
obtain more or email them to you
um generally speaking the department
again does not have a position on the
underlying policy of this of
hp504 um however as a generally speaking
uh this bill is written does not does
not align with current statutory
constructs under our jurisdiction um and
a significant rewrite of it would be
required to make it work for us um more
significant I'd say than the first bill
we testified on
1502 um additionally as you've noted
there's a pretty significant um fiscal
impact of uh this legislation as written
um as detailed in the fiscal note um so
what I've done is I provided a handout
um I think most of the issues here lie
in the fact that as you stated uh as
chairman hunt stated the uh Wyoming
structure um was taken in this bill and
doesn't really match what we we what we
do with the New Hampshire banking
Department um the handout that I've
distributed kind of gives the highlevel
highlights of the big picture issues um
that would need to be addressed on a
procedural matter um to make this work
for us at the banking Department um
specifically I won't read my hand out
now but specifically um the big one that
stands out a couple of big ones that
stand out to us are you know I think
what I think how Wyoming works is they
have board that Charters banks in New
Hampshire we um got rid of the it was
called the botsy board I think the B
ster board but at any rate bsy it was
several years ago in 2015 I believe
there was a significant rewrite that
board was eliminated this bill um
essentially I think requires a board
like that so right now the um chartering
Authority for um Banks or depository
institutions or trust companies rests
with the bank commissioner solely so
that's kind of one big picture thing
additionally as has been discussed uh a
few times now um is how the banking
Department in New Hampshire is funded is
very different than in Wyoming so any
reference to funding in this bill
whether it's like taking fees or um
examination costs that would all need to
be reworked to match how we are
currently funded at the banking
Department um let's see I'm trying to
kind of summarize because I know we've
been here for a while um another big
picture issue is there's um safety and
soundness Provisions in our law that
govern how um chartered institutions
operate um and what we examine for um
those are pretty clear in particularly
in our trust trust company laws they
don't line up they they I mean there
might be some overlap but um we find
that the ones that we have work best for
us in New Hampshire um so we would need
to really look carefully at those
Provisions also our Provisions are very
consistent with federal law because for
banks we go in and regulate banks with
our federal counterparts um and it's
important that those what we're looking
for kind of aligns nicely um and that's
it's not that it couldn't be done it
just needs to be looked over um pretty
carefully um so that's kind of the big
picture things in my handout um I wanted
to mention too that um at the very end
of the bill there's um reference to RSA
399 G that exemption that I um
referenced in my earlier testimony I
would just caution you that any changes
to that it took a lot of work to kind of
get that to where we needed it to be and
I would it probably would take a lot of
work to review the proposed changes here
to get them to where we want them to be
um a couple of other like little nuances
just to you know I didn't I don't want
to go line by line through the bill and
point out all like the the issues but
you could there's almost every line
would probably need to be changed a
little bit um so um and it's not to say
that it couldn't be done it would just
need some work um some big ones that
stand out of those kind of needly
nuanced things um putting aside the big
procedural things uh for example and I
apologize again I was not able to print
out the line by line number version of
the bill before I came here um but there
is a part of the bill in 383 F4 that
references make making an application to
become a member of the Federal Reserve
System in order to do that you have to
qualify for FDIC insurance and then
below that it talks about how these
entities will not qualify for FDIC
Insurance um just just you know it you
can work through that problem it would
just need some time to be work how did
Wyoming work through it I don't I don't
know I don't I don't know exactly
because I I didn't I haven't gone
through this line by line with wyom
right um and it could be that none of
their institutions are interested in
that provision because it's an optional
provision um you know it doesn't they're
not requ it's just enabling the yeah so
it could be that the four that are in
Wyoming don't aren't interested in that
but you know it is a Nuance that you
have to be aware of
um uh let's see some other issues um so
I also wanted to address um currently
under current law the um New Hampshire
banking Department charters has two
Charter types A State Bank and a credit
union underneath a State Bank there are
three types of three flavors of State
Banks there's a a depository bank
there's a Trust Company trust a non-
depository trust company and then
there's a Family Trust Company um a
private Family Trust Company so I would
assume that you would want to put this
somehow under the def the umbrella of a
state bank to make it work but that's
that needs to be reconciled
um with the bill currently
um no let's it contemplate now it seems
to contemplate it seems I yeah seems to
contemplate a separate Standalone
Charter type okay um maybe maybe that's
appropriate um but I I frankly I think
that is yeah I mean I I don't want
anybody to be confused that they're a
bank so I would almost change you know
so you might want to I would almost
require that they they write
SD
in their name yep almost yeah and I
think that to the extent this interplays
with 1502 that references just a bank
you might want to just you just got to
be mindful of all these Bank references
we don't like that word we don't want
them anybody to think they're a bank
yeah yeah so I you know again it's just
a Nuance that would need to be
contemplated
um
so I I could keep going with issues but
um but I'm happy to to answer any
questions you may have um certainly how
long will it take you to make it to make
it work uh well we'd have to go like I
said if you saw my if you could see my
notes on this it's almost every chunk
needs something um changing a little bit
you know it's not it's not unworkable um
certainly Wyoming doesn't we have a good
relationship with Wyoming and can talk
to them and kind of work through some of
these issues but some of it is just
fundamentally Wyoming just runs
differently than New Hampshire um so it
would takes some some some pretty
significant work I I am shocked about
the 91a piece you that is unbelievable
yeah that's that's an issue that needs
to be thought about did that W said did
did they see I'm not I haven't gone line
by line and compared um uh so a lot of
this you haven't really seen what's
their actual statue well I haven't like
lined it up like one for one we've
talked to Wyoming in pretty broad terms
about it but in terms of really going
line by line you know I I don't know and
I don't know what they're policy
considerations were if they did make
that call
um
so okay um and I'm happy to answer any
questions I am and I have Nancy who's my
expert in trust companies to the extent
there's overlap right well and I would
say that as the sponsor of the original
trust law um it was in in that case it
was different I wasn't we weren't
lifting it from some other place we
actually had a room full of trust
lawyers it was a double room like this
and it was packed full of lawyers and
they literally you know we went through
every piece but we were building on the
case law we were building on what is was
already occurring case law in New
Hampshire in this case we're it's there
is no case law right has been any case
law and that we're now trying to create
something that is modeling theoretically
off of somebody else who already put
their feet in the water yeah I I would
add to that too that this talks a lot
about
custody and there's lots of different I
couldn't begin to listen Nancy's much
better than me there's lots of trust
companies that do lots of different
types of custody work correct um and it
could be that some of this already fits
within that world I you know it we'd
have to really understand what somebody
would want to do to see it to the extent
some of it might fit in Trust Company
world I don't know um but that's another
discussion that could be had with more
detail good
any questions from the committee
members I guess I guess they finally got
it all figured out now yeah or I st them
sorry all right good job thank
you thank you all right last but not
least Christy Merill and Ryan
hail and you're not really going to take
minutes
good afternoon again thank you Mr
chairman and honorable members of the
House Commerce Committee I will try to
go quickly we also have a lot to say on
this um I'm christe Merl president of
New Hampshire Bankers Association and
with me is Ryan hail um even though this
legislation it doesn't say it expressly
understanding is that it's designed to
allow institutions to hold in transfer
virtual currencies including crypto and
digital
assets um as I've said earlier given the
increasingly digital nature of our
transactions um a lot of our banks are
open to and interested in digital assets
and crypto and they ultimately would
like the option to partner with
companies working in the space and also
to increase their their digital
offerings um one example that I want to
point out if you're not aware um Walden
Mutual is presently seeking a charter
with the new Hampshire banking
department and if they're approved
they'll be the first new Mutual Bank in
decades I think actually 99 years in New
Hampshire um and within uh nationally I
think it's the first in 50 years but
they would be an institution that would
have a primarily digital footprint so I
think they are evidence um that New
Hampshire is at the Forefront of
thinking about these types of ideas and
how the needs of financial consumers are
evolving and increasing
online um with respect to Virtual
currencies there are several Banks acoss
Ross the country that have made the
decision to get in the space um just a
few examples you may have heard of
silvergate Bank in California they're
one of the leading banks in the space
and they accepted 4.3 billion in
deposits from new and existing digital
currency customers in the second quarter
of 2021 Alone um US Bank recently
announced it will provide custody
services for fund managers and these are
just a couple of examples of banks that
are in the space and there are many more
um engaged and others looking to do so
as well and we know there are other
banks that are reluctant to take the
plunge until the Federal Banking uh
Regulators create clear
guidance as introduced this proposal
establishes a regulatory framework to
allow a new class of banks um that would
be able to hold uninsured deposits has
been addressed uh and is similar to a
law in
Wyoming um they would carry non-lending
business for depositors provide payment
services apply to become a member of the
FED reserve and engage in other business
of banking
um even though it establishes a new type
of Bank Charter it would not be treated
like a Traditional Bank in a lot of
important ways um besides not being
insured by the FDIC and we understand
that the sponsor tries to address that
um but it also won't be regulated by a
federal agency these are very
significant policy considerations um for
the legislature and for you all to
consider and uh there are other issues
that we want to point out um this being
coupled with the ability to apply for a
Federal Reserve master account exposes
consumers and the payment system and if
a bank fails today we know that
consumers are assured their deposits are
protected um through the FDC insurance
if this passes a bank chartered under
this new framework and if it fails it's
unclear how the depositors would be
impacted um and this raises concerns
about consumer protections as well as
subjecting the traditional banking
system to reputational risk um I just
want to kind of go through some of the
other issues we want to highlight um as
been discussed this this legislation
places the sole responsibility on the
New Hampshire banking
Department um we've there's been some
discussion about the fiscal note this
will put a tremendous amount of pressure
on them and like a lot of other New
Hampshire businesses they're having
their own Workforce issues it's very
difficult to hire right now um the
fiscal note indicates they'll have to
hire and train seven new staff um incur
expenses totaling three and a half
million over the next three years and um
it's not clear to us how the department
will locate these individuals with the
requisite expertise to to provide safe
and sound regulatory oversight um and
just an example of this um in the
Department's review of these new
applications one of the criteria that
the department has to evaluate is the
adequacy Imp plausibility plausibility
of the business plan of the special
purpose depository institution um I
think it's obvious that this will be uh
require a very sophisticated employee
with expertise and and um experience in
this field our next issue we want to
highlight has to do with supervision um
as also been mentioned but when it comes
to safety and soundness a New Hampshire
Chartered Bank they're examined every 18
months on a rotational basis by the New
Hampshire banking department and the
FDIC or the Federal
Reserve in this under this legislation
it's left to the banking Department to
establish rules on the frequency um
that's concerning to us we think it
should be a matter of policy to set the
schedule for what the supervision would
be um and we would Advocate that it
should be at least every 18 months um
and given the risk profile of these
novel Technologies ongoing may be
appropriate for a shorter for a period
of time um given how fast this area is
evolving another issue we want to raise
is has to do with public reporting Banks
and Credit Unions today they have to
provide quarterly reports that are known
um they report condition and income
they're known as call reports so given
the the risk profile of these new
technologies uh what would we would
request that there be some type of
scheduled public disclosure of audited
financial
statements um moving on to the financial
impact to the depository Banks there's
been some discussion about how the
banking department is funded and we
recognize that it does create a new
accounting unit that supervises the
Speedy Charters um but it does
explicitly say that the the application
fee is limited to the cost of the
Department's review and so we would just
ask the question where the funding to
set this up would come from um and
practically speaking with just a large
fiscal note and the impact of the
department will New Hampshire Charter
banks have to pay to help set this up
because that would be a concern of
ours we also just want to point out the
effective date of um July one I'm sorry
if my time up is that what no I
got oh okay okay sorry about that um
with effective data of July 1 2022 uh we
that is concerning and we're not sure
how the department would be able to
staff up in time before a new Charter
start coming in um it's our
understanding in Wyoming just a few
months after this became law they began
um they started receiving
applications so I think ultimately a
question for us is why this legislation
is needed um it appears that this would
create a new type of Bank um that does
not have the oversight of federal
Federal Regulators but would have access
to the FED
Reserve um as has been mentioned there
have been four Charters approved Speedy
charters in Wyoming and their law allows
that um but the Kansas City fed has yet
to respond to those
applications um and I believe actually
chairman Powell commented on this just
yesterday before the Senate Banking
Committee um about regarding questions
on Where the FED is on granting access
um they've said that it's is going to be
coming soon they issued a notice of
proposed rulemaking a year ago um and I
think their goal is to really create
uniform standards in terms of how that
access is granted um and the purpose is
to create a consistent and transparent
approach to be used by all the reserve
banks um they don't have final rules out
yet is my
understanding um just we do want to
point out there's a lot of U movement
here on the federal level uh last
November the fed the FDIC and the OCC
they issued ued a joint statement on
crypto asset policy Sprint initiative
and the next steps and their whole goal
was to address the rapidly evolving
technology and they plan to look at how
Banks can safely offer and expand their
crypto
offerings um in their review you know
they put time and resources into looking
at these issues and their initial
conclusion was that they needed more
time um they've outlined their work and
what it's expected to cover in 2022 and
we've included that for you all to take
um so just kind of the the last point
that we want to um raise with you all is
um the unlevel playing field I think
there's a concern that you know we have
banks that continue to move in New
Hampshire and that speaks well about New
Hampshire's economy and you know our
banks are very used to competition they
don't shy away from that um and our
members are are good corporate citizens
and they take their commitment to
supporting their communities and the
nonprofit seriously um you all have
probably heard from us before in other
legislation that the regulatory
challenges and the burdens on Community
Banks um has definitely contributed to
the increased trend of mergers and
Acquisitions and along with fewer Banks
being created so um this type of Charter
We Believe would result in tipping the
scales against Community Banks and would
create an unlevel playing
field um we don't believe that
cryptocurrency is going away anytime
soon and the digitization of
transactions will only continue to rise
including in banking um and our banks
are working to make progress in the
space and meet the demands of their
customers as they continue to evolve um
but we don't believe this is the way to
move it forward so for all these reasons
we're in opposition and we would um ask
for an expedient to legislate and we're
questions questions
so I'm a little confused um it it
sounded like this is something the banks
that exist in New Hampshire already
might want to
do so rather than creating a new
division shouldn't we be working towards
allowing our New Hampshire Banks the
people who are already in the state to
do this um chairman hun I think we would
agree that that's certainly um
it okay well
committee
right uh I guess we're all set thank
you uh let's see so do I have the right
build now what's my blue sheets blue
sheets blue sheets what I do blue sheet
I thought I thought I had them
uh that's
it all right um we're just waiting for
the blue sheet that's not it
I maybe I got it here there I think it
got lost in the pile here 1504 all
right so we had uh one One support and
34 uh posed to to the bill
electronically and then uh pretty much
the same uh Suzanne Smith representa
Smith is opposed representative
Alexander and representative Warden are
in support and Lisa tap is also in
support and with that I will close the
public
hearing um I have
scheduled the subcommittee uh for this
bill it will be on Wednesday the
26th and I think think it's going to be
at
10:15
A.M and with
done
e